e
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne and W
house Jour from the session of May 2nd
2024 you're ready for the question all
those in favor say I those close nay the
eyes have it in the house is adjourned
house will attend to a Prayer by guest
chaplain Reverend Reed ly director of St
good morning
morning in my in my tradition we speak
of prayer first of all as a response to
God that is a response to love as we
have known love so while I will pray in
the words and the form familiar to me I
hope that in these words you may find
your own Spirit of response to love as
God source of wisdom whose will is life
whose Reigns fall upon rich and poor
alike who calls every child my child
whose perfect love always exceeds our
understanding yet who draws us ever
closer guide the legislature of this
state here
assembled that in their discourse in
word and silence
our greatest wisdom may be
revealed that the laws they enact May
embody though this word itself be all
but absent from our rsas that their were
their laws May embody
love and sustain the welfare of all
people and that their example May renew
the ties of mutual regard which form our
Civic
life and if these high callings are in
any way unlooked for in our time or
among our peers give them strength and
good humor to depart expectations in
favor of the surprise of Good Will and
New
Life by the name in which we rise to our
amen the chair recognizes the member
from hookit representative John levit
Allegiance i plge al
of the United States of America and to
the for it stands one nation
all the chair now recognizes Caitlyn
Barberry who will sing our national
anthem
[Music]
dawn
light once so
proud
twi
cleaning who BR stries and bright
[Music]
the
fight for
the we
[Music]
watch were so
G
streaming and the
[Music]
BBS
bur
in gave proof through the
night that our flag was still
go all the
land of
[Music]
the and the
[Applause]
[Music]
Speaker the house will attend to request
for Lees of absence Mr Speaker the day
illness Representatives Buco Gibbs
O'Brien and Steven Pearson the day
important business Representatives
William Dolan Damon Ford Hobson Hull
infantine McBeth O'Hara Traer verville
the day illness in the family
representative Katherine Harvey the day
death in the family Representatives
Richard and
shamberg these Le of abion shall be
granted unless otherwise ordered by the
house
guest Mr Speaker please welcome Melissa
levit Kim Murphy and Emanuel dress
driver family of the singer guests of
Representative levit marad Durkin wife
of Representative Durkin Leanne kuger
guest of Representative Vale Buzz Sher
guest of Representative hamblet Suzanne
kedan guest of Representative hyr Jim
Gruber guest of Representative Shapiro
Rachel G an and Jessica marison guests
of Representative stab William black and
Allison Schwarz guest of Representative
hackin Phillips fourth grade students
from molten Boro Central School guests
of Representatives Crawford mcon costal
and Richard Brown and fourth grade
students from grenell elementary school
guests of Representative puchek they are
with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will attend to a house
resolution chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker house resolution
35 whereas the National Conference of
state legislatures was founded in 1975
as the result of the merger of three
organizations that represented state
legislators who shared the belief that
legislative service is one of democracy
worthiest Pursuits and whereas the
National Conference of state legislator
is a bipartisan organization whose
mission is to advance the effectiveness
Independence and integrity of
Institutions to Foster Interstate
communication and cooperation and to
ensure States a strong cohesive voice in
the federal system and whereas the
National Conference of State Legislature
not only serves all members of the
legislature across the country but
offers professional development
opportunities for all legislative staff
as
well whereas New Hampshire has provided
presidents of the National Conference of
State legislatures members and staff
have served on its executive committee
and its several standing committees
staff has served of presidents and board
members and chairs of various staff
associations Under the Umbrella of ncsl
and whereas ncsl serves as a resource to
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives expressing the
importance of the first branch of
government now therefore be it resolved
that the New Hampshire House of
Representatives in regular session
convened recognizes commends and
celebrates the National Conference of
State Legislature as they begin their
50th year and further resolve that a
suitable copy of this resolution be
presented to ncsl and prepared by the
clerk of the house and duly transmitted
to them are you ready for the question
all those favor say I I those oppose nay
adopted New Hampshire's historic ties
with Japan go back at least as far as
1905 when under President Theodore
Roosevelt the treaty ended the Russo
Japanese war was signed in Portsmouth in
September of that
year we are proud of our historical
connection to Japan and will continue to
work with them to strengthen our
relationship Our Guest Ambassador Suzuki
cataro has nearly 35 years of expensive
experience in foreign Ministry and
political Affairs his work in diplomacy
showcases his ability to build
relationships and successfully represent
thriving Japanese communities here in
New England Please give a warm welcome
to council General Consulate General in
Boston Ambassador Suzuki qaro and former
ambassador to Iraq and Deputy Council
General
[Music]
[Applause]
speaker parer Deputy speaker Smiths
Majority Leader minority
wilham representatives of the house and
distinguished guests oh good morning I
am the council general of
Japan in Boston Karo Suzuki since
1980 the con general of Japan in Boston
has served the Six States of New England
as a representative of the Japanese
government and people I am honored to be
given the opportunity to speak here
today in this historic chamber to the
representatives of the people of New
Hampshire
first of all I would like to express my
deep respect to the state house and the
people of the state government who work
so hard for the people of the State of
New Hampshire the home of the United
States its independence its Constitution
and its democracy embodied by its
citizens who elect their representatives
to decide their rules and way of
life before I speak to you the current
states of J Japan us relation as a
Japanese Diplomat I would like to talk
about the origins of this important
bilateral
relationship the relationship of these
two peoples of these two countries on
opposite sides of the white Pacific
began in the first half of the 19th
century with a chance meeting of one
American ship captain and a young
Japanese boy that boy John mango is
considered to be one of the first
Japanese in history to step foot in the
United States
in the year
1841 the 14 years old mango the son of a
l fisherman was trying to support his
mother and siblings with a group of
fishermen but one day strong winds
forced their boat out to sea after 5
days of
drifting he and his Shipmates washed up
on the deserted Islands they managed to
survive there for nearly half a year
before they was discovered and rescued
by a passing American waiting ship
commanded by Captain William
Whitfield after bringing his Shipmates
safely to Hawaii Captain Whitfield
brought John with him to his family
residence in F Haven Massachusetts where
he had joined educated as his adopted
son after learning subjects like English
arithmetic and Maritime navigation out
of his own determination mango toward
world as a member of a weding boat and
even worked as a 49er during the
California Gold Rush to save money to
return to
Japan alluding to his own travels the
poet Robert Frost once wrote of his
shoes on one I can taste Atlantic on the
other Pacific
Souls M could add to that in fact he had
saved the seven
seeds however what gave him those
opportunities and his skills in first
place was the humanity and Goodwill of
one American ship cap captain that
brought him across the Pacific and
sported
him having earned the necessary funds to
return to Japan mango succeeded in doing
just that in
1851 and after a long period of
questioning by the Tokugawa government
he was allowed to return to his
childhood home in
1853 the 26 yearold now was uh finally
able to reunite with his mother and tell
people about his time in America he
would later play a vital role in
developing Japan us
relations the same year John mango
returned to the family in Japan in 1853
an event of great magnitude in terms of
international relations and modern
Japanese history was taking place one
considered to Mark the starting point of
Japan us
relations the arrival of the Black Ships
commanded by us commod Matthew
P for over 200 years Japan had been
closed off from foreign countries this
event began the process of opening
Japan's ports to trade with the outside
world and to the modernization of Japan
America at the time desired Supply ports
for coal and other resources on the
opposite shs of the Pacific due to
burgeoning trade with China and the
expansion of the whing industry in the
region they also wanted to secure
Japanese aid for their Shipwrecked
sailors
sometime before this in
1851 Daniel Webster then serving as
Secretary of State wrote to the
Secretary of the Navy regarding the
possibility of sending us naval ships to
Japan to negotiate a repatriation for
rescue Japanese Sailors and the opening
up of Japan as well as the establishment
of trade
relations the very next day a letter of
Amity intended for the emperor of Japan
was drafted by President Filmore who
approved of the plan and was
countersigned by secretary
Webster in November
1852 commod mat Perry uh the commander
of the East India Squadron was on his
way to Japan with four military
vessels to deliver the letter won rout
in March
1853 Franklin Pierce became the new
president of the United
States in July Paris Fleet finally
arrived in Japan after visiting several
other countries the Ado governments
could not agree to open their ports
immediately and requested one year to
consider President Pierce had instructed
Perry that he achieved their objectives
strictly through diplomatic means so he
agreed in September of the same year
Franklin Pierce became the first US
president to meet with another Japanese
citizen when he met with Joseph KIRO who
had also been rescued by an American
merchant
ship Perry returned to Japan the
following year
1854 and negotiated with the Japanese
delegation resulting in the Japan us
Treaty of peace and Amity which
designated two ports to be open for
trade 170 years ago this document
established foral relations between the
US and Japan and the first International
treaty Japan signed with a foreign
country in modern times ending Japan's
period of self-imposed isolation John
mango acted as an advisor during this
negotiations in
1854 sorry In 1855 following the
stipulation of the treaty President
Pierce appointed town and Harris at the
first American Cil in Japan and invested
him with full diplomatic power to pursue
form of trade between the two Nations
the result of this his efforts was the
18 19 58 signing of the Treaty of armity
and commerce between the US and Japan
the second Treaty of the two two
countries main out trining
trade with this treaty Paris also became
the first diplomatic Envoy from the
United States to reside in
Japan honorable Representatives I wanted
to share with you this historic truth
that 170 years ago at the beginning of
Japan us relations leaders born in New
Hampshire made these important decisions
there is another Treaty of great
significance in Japan Japanese and world
history the pzas treaty was a peace
treaty ending the Russia Japanese war
signed in pmas in the year of
195 the war commanded the great
attention of the international Society
at the time as the small Northeastern
island nation of Japan not long after
being down its path of modernization
effectively defeated Russia one of the
world's great
Powers Japan hoping to avoid a prolonged
War aimed for peace from the early point
of in the INF in the conflict and asked
for the United States assistance
immediately after the world turned in
Japan's favor after victory in the
battle of the Japan C president Theodore
roselt strongly recommended a peace
treaty to Russia Russia struggling to
suppress its domestic revolutionary
movements
accepted in August 195 Japanese Russian
delegations arrived in pmas and the
peace negotiations were held although
talks were difficult the pmas peace
treaty was signed between jutaro comra
representing Japan and ser representing
Russia at the poas Naval
Shipyard civilian diplomacy by the
people of Bas set a stage for the
success of the negotiations under the
new hampsher government led by Governor
John mlan when the peace talks
encountered difficulties the citizens of
poas held theatrical performances
baseball games and celebrations to
encourage diplomats to continue with the
negotiations the hotel that hosted both
delegations went was by the sea has been
prepare preserved through the efforts of
many people beginning with the Japan
America Society of New Hampshire and the
citizens of Po and its sister city jut
comrad hometown of
Nan in 2005 the city of pmas held a
magnificent ceremony to Mark the
Centenary of the portas treaty and in
2010 to commemorate the great role
civilian diplomacy plays in the historic
treaty the New Hampshire State
Legislature unanimously voted to
designate September the 5th as poas
peace treaty day on which the governor
releases a proclamation every
year in addition every year on that day
portas and nich uh BOS hold a b ringing
C ceremony to wish for
peace to uh for all your efforts over
the years I express my gratitude to the
citizens also worth mentioning when
speaking of the long-standing friendship
between the United States and Japan are
the territories along the pmma river in
Washington DC cherry blossoms have been
a special flower to Japanese for over
over 10 centuries and I think that many
Americans recognize them as a symbol of
Japan as
well after visiting Japan in
1885 American journalist Eliza sedore
proposed the idea of planting cherry
trees along the pmak river to the US
government at first no one lent an year
to her proposal but 20 years later first
lady Helen agreed to make a row of
charry trees in Washington DC with
support from Japanese scientists and
diplomats in the US in
1912 3,000 cherry trees were sent to the
United States as a gift from the mayor
of Tokyo Yukio
oaki and planted along the pmar now yuk
oaki is still revealed today as the god
of Japan's constitutional government for
his distinguished career of 63
consecutive years as a member of
parliament he was elected 25 times for
from the beginning of Japan's modern era
to the post World War II period and one
of the reasons why he decided to send
the cherry trees was to thank the people
of the US in supporting the portas peace
treaty negotiation
process in 2012 Cher trees were planted
in pmas as living Monument to the G
treaty and I'm aware that since then
cherry trees have been planted elsewhere
around New Hampshire it is my hope that
these trees Will Be Loved for many years
to come as a symbol of the friendship
goodwi and citizen diplomacy shared
between Japan the United States and
Hampshire today Japan and the US share a
deep bond that is stronger than ever
before last month prime minister kishida
made an official visit to the United
States as a state gift of Honor on this
visit Three broad points were
highlighted first the strength of the
friendship and trust between the two
leaders and the people of both
countries the Japan us relationship is
supported by a broad cross-section of
society second through these bonds Japan
and the US have become Global Partners
Beyond bilateral or Regional spheres to
uphold and bolster the free and open
International order based on the rule of
law third Japan the US should continue
their cooperation especially in Cutting
Edge areas to drive sustainable and
together with the increasing
increasingly serious issues the world is
facing the Japan us Alliance is more
important than ever we hope that the
Pacific Ocean countries sorry um Pacific
Ocean continues to be a sea of Peace
open to free exchange and trade
throughout the 20 121st
century 21st century
sorry and that the relations of the
Pacific including
Japan the nations of the Pacific
including Japan will continue to enjoy
that freedom and peace during his visits
prime minister kishida strongly affirmed
Japan's commitment to stand with the
United
States in fulfilling its responsibility
to uphold Regional and international
peace and
stability AS Global Partners Japan will
work together to the realization of a
free and open Indo Pacific which is to
the benefits of not just Japan and the
United States but the entire
world in economy and business Japan us
relationship is more Rob robust than
ever with the two economies deeply
integrated through trade and
investment since 2019 Japan has been the
world's largest investor in the United
States with Japanese companies creating
almost 1 million jobs in the
US the recent joint statement
highlights the first sorry the further
revitalization of mutual private sector
investment and public private
Partnerships between the two countries
as well as the strengthening of
cooperation emerging Technologies such
as AI Quantum technology semiconductors
climate change and clean energy through
this enhanced collaboration and
investment we can expect the economic
tithe between Japan and the US to grow
even stronger going
forward New Hampshire with its vast and
Rich natural environment has seen
notable industrial growth and on top of
Tourism now thrives in its manufacturing
sector focusing on
conductors and aircraft Parts as well as
in its science and technology related
Industries New Hampshire also has uh
developed deep economic ties with
Japan there are 88 Japanese companies
operating in the states employing
4,700 people moreover with 314 million
dollars in export to Japan last year the
economic relationship with Japan and the
New Hampshire is strong and is expected
to progress even
further honorable
Representatives looking back at the
origins of the relationship between our
two Nations separated by a vast ocean it
began with the courageous and virtuous
meeting of two peoples who crossed that
ocean the people of New Hampshire have
contributed greatly to the relationship
both as leaders in government and as
Citizens the history is history each of
our Nations have to cope with the
reality of our own era and both of us
face numerous challenge challenges in
this
Century yet the Japan us
relationship will continue to deepen AS
Global
Partners since so many of our challenges
are common since we are stronger by
teaming up
but above all since this relationship
people in The Joint statement the two
leaders committed to these bonds the
Consulate General of Japan is also
commited to promoting this relationship
and exploring further possibilities of
mutual cooperation in New England and in
the States you all represent I greatly
appreciate your continuous support
towards these
efforts I thank you very much for
inviting me here today I appreciate your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
the chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker the Senate concurs with the
house in the passage of the following
entitled bill with Amendment the passage
of which amendment the Senate as concur
to the house house bill
398 relative to notice of P
contamination prior to the sale of real
property representative rul moves we
concur is recognized as speak
representative rulu moves we Concur and
the house will be in order now just a
obviously as just starting today uh is
the motion to motion is to concur
okay okay I'd like to move on House Bill
398 uh that uh we can that the house
concur with the uh recommendation with
our recommendation on on that bill
can I uh
the the bill house 398
requires a certain notice of P of past
and other uh groundwater contaminations
prior to the sale of
property the all the Senate did was add
they actually removed one word the uh
the sentence was testing of the Water by
a accredited laboratory can measure past
levels and inform a home buyer's
decision regarding the need to install
water treatment systems the Senate
removed the word home and that's it uh
at a publicly notice executive session
the r R&D committee recommended to
concur
unanimously the motion before us is to
concur on Senate Bill 398 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I oppos nay the eyes the eyes have it
and the motion
passes chair recogniz the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate concurs with the house in the
passor of the following entitled bill
with amendment that passes which
amendment the Senate ask concurrence of
the house house bill 1060 relative to
establishing a geologic resources
committee representes wecr is recognized
representative moves that we concurrent
motion
okay all right house bills 1060 the bill
establishes a geologic resource advisory
committee in the Department of
Environmental Services to serve the role
of the state mapping advisory committee
as required by the national Cooperative
there is a as a list of in the list of
who is on the commission there is a uh
item I which says a member of the public
the Senate changed it to a member of the
public appointed by the commissioner of
the Department of Environmental
Services the other
is the Senate added a language about who
calls this first meeting in other words
it's the sentence added is the meeting
shall be called by the state geologic
geologist and the director of the New
Hampshire Geological Survey at the
Department of Environmental services at
a publicly noticed executive session of
the rr&d committee the committee
recommended to concur
unanimously thank
you the motion before us is to concur on
House Bill 1060 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it and the
motion
passes the house will now attend to the
consent
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on children and family law Senate Bill
574 removed by Representatives Christine
Perez kutab Tom Manion Ankerberg post
papichi Muller weie Spain ball and
kushman from the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety Senate Bill
426 removed by Representatives alisandra
Murray Tom Manion Granger Phillips yella
Ellen Reed Noble Tony leus kulan and
costal from the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety Senate Bill
508 removed by Representatives Ankerberg
Granger Ellen Reed Tom minion Bickford
Santa naso papichi Mueller kulon wheeler
and Bailey from the committee on
executive departments and administration
Senate Bill 481 removed by
Representatives alisandra Murray nutting
Wong Gallagher Damon selig MC Williams
Horgan are there any other bills removed
representative Osborne moves that the
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments is printed in today's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
it house will now attend to the regular
calendar
okay the Committee on Public Works and
highways to which was referred Senate
Bill 592 FN in act renaming Route 127
from Central Street to Franklin in
Franklin to the to line of sand Bron as
office of Broadley house Memorial
Highway considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment Senator Mark mccon
for the committee the amendment is
14528 printed in house record 18 page 47
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
makoni thank you Mr Speaker uh
members members of the house it's my
honor today to deliver the following
remarks for my committee Public Works
and
highways Bradley hos was working as a
security officer at the New Hampshire
hospital in
conquer when a gunman opened fire in the
front lobby despite efforts to save him
hos died of his
injuries hos was working for the
Department of Safety at the time of the
shooting before that he spent 28 years
with the Franklin New Hampshire Police
Department starting as a patrol officer
and eventually being named chief he
retired from the Department in 2008 and
he was also a US
veteran I would like to share a quote
from New Hampshire Attorney John feno
who said Chief hos is already a hero
when he walked into work yesterday
yesterday given his service to our
country to our state and to his
community he will now be remembered as a
man who died protecting patients staff
and visitors to the New Hampshire
hospital Brad grew up in Franklin and
attended Franklin High School he went to
serve his country as a military police
officer in the US Army before becoming a
police offer officer in his hometown of
Franklin Brad served his community for
26 years and as a respected officer and
leader he became the chief of police for
the city of
Franklin after retirement Brad worked
for the US Postal Service and then as a
security officer for the State of New
Hampshire at the New Hampshire
hospital while I was never fortunate
enough to meet Brad people that I have
talked to have said he was a kind loving
person who was committed to his family
friends his community his State and his
nation that is all Illustrated in his
career in
service importantly Brad enjoyed time
with his son and they had much in common
as Fathers and Sons do Brad was always
we can never understand this senseless
act nothing we can say or do will bring
Chief hos back to his
family but here today we can ensure that
all that drive through Franklin on Route
127 will be reminded of Brad's
commitment to his town and family each
time they traveled this section of road
to be now named the Bradley House
Memorial Highway
may God bless Chief Bradley hos his
family friends and asked that he protect
all those that serve in law
enforcement firefighters and First
Responders here in our
state finally we extend our deepest
sympathies to your
family please join me in unanimously
vote this legislation out ought to pass
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on Senate Bill 592 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those oppos nay you guys have it on
objection for for the record for the for
the record do you have to make the
official
motion
yeah I jumped the
gun go ahead go ahead thank you Mr
Speaker I moved that the remarks from
the debate on Senate
Bill 592 be printed in the permanent
committee on children and family law to
which was referred Senate Bill 459 FN an
act establishing a committee to study
the child protection act having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment Senator Mark Pearson for
the
committee the amendment is 1688 H
printed in house record 18 page page 44-
45 chair recognize representative Mark
Pearson thank you Mr Speaker there is a
drafting error in that committee
Amendment and thank you to the first
term representative from what to me is
the opposite party for catching this
error so I'm asking please vote no on
the committee Amendment even though it
was unanimous in committee but then
please vote Yes to the floor Amendment
which fixes the drafting error thank you
Mr
Speaker the motion before us is
amendment 1688 H are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay the Nays have it the amendment is
defeated bills on second reading open to
further Amendment representative Pearson
and this it's in your seat Pockets chair
recognize representative Mark
Pearson this fixes the drafting error
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is a
Pearson floor Amendment 17598 are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I oppose
nay the eyes have it in the floor
amendment is adopted representative
Granger has asked for a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
yes it is sufficiently seconded this
clear the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on Senate Bill 459 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button St
well make sure your stations are
open voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
vote you is 70 voting a 94 voting a
committee report is
adopted okay this is without
recommendation
committee on Election law to which was
referred Senate Bill 537 FN allowing the
processing of absentee ballots it comes
without recommendation s of Lane moves
ought to pass and offers floor Amendment
1852 H it's in your seat
Pockets the chair recognizes
sorry sorry Mr Speaker the clerk and I
were having a conversation um I rise
today to speak against the floor
Amendment uh what the floor Amendment
does is it changes this horrible Bill
and tries to make it a little better um
but Mr Speaker um making going from
mandatory to optional is just a Gateway
back to mandatory so it's a bad bill
there's no point trying to make it
better I urge the body to oppose the
floor Amendment
Brenan oh I'm sorry my mistake
representative
Wayne thank you Mr Speaker um this
amendment addresses the two major issues
that were raised by the clerks in the
public hearing on the bill as it stands
now the bill requires at least two days
of partial processing for absente
ballots and does not provide them any
guidance on how to cure those absentee
ballots that have correctable defects
the amendment makes the pre-processing
optional so it's an enabling act for a
period of up to two days and requires
the clerks to follow the guidance that
the secretary of state will issue in the
election manual this amendment has been
approved by Matt Norman the Manchester
cler clerk who opposed the version
passed by the Senate and by Dan Healey
the Nashua Clerk and the president of
the clerk
Association the amendment provides the
clerks with a tool in the event they
receive a large number of absentee
ballots right now they would have to
rely on another emergency executive
order issued by the governor as was done
in
2020 they prefer to know that this
optional processing is a tool that's in
their toolbox if they decide it's needed
in their town the amendment requires the
clerks to follow the instructions of the
secretary state with regard to curing
correctable defects on the outer
envelope contrary to what um you may he
curing an absentee ballot does not
create two classes of Voters inperson
voters have three opportunities to cure
their ballots this amendment Returns the
ballot the bill to what was originally
requested by the clerks when they
approached the senate for legislation I
ask that you support our hardworking
clerks moderators and poll workers by
providing them the management tools that
they have requested please vote for the
amendment and I ask Mr Speaker for a
division
vote so Lan has requested a division
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote representative M represent mcarter
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1852 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Barry for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that I was one of the co-p
sponsors of cannabis legalization this
year and Mr Speaker if I know that while
I have questions about marijuana being a
gateway drug I know optional is a
gateway drug to man to mandatory would I
now vote red to oppose this amendment
chair recognized representer Brenan for
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment adequately addresses concerns
raised during the public hearing
and if I know this amendment was
requested and is supported by our
trusted local election officials who
actually do the work of running our safe
secure efficient elections would I now
press the green button to support the
amendment thank you m the motion before
us is a to pass on floor Amendment 18528
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 180 voting aay 185 voting a the
amendment
fails
motion for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
537 I would like to make a motion to
table Mr Speaker high priority tabling
is a higher priority so the motion
537 represent request representative
Barry requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
here
motion before us to the table Senate
Bill 537 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair Rec andiz represent L for
parliamentary
inquiry if I know that this bill is not
supported by the clerks Association and
other clerks at is as it has come to us
from across the wall then would I press
motion chair recognize representative
Barry for a parliamentary in thank you
Mr Speaker Mr Mr Speaker if I know that
this bill is opposed by the clerk's
Association would I oppose the tabling
motion so that we could go back to the
underlying motion and put this bill in
the garbage where it
inappropriate the motion before us is
the table Senate Bill
537 if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your oppos you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
all members present had an opportunity
vote 180 voting aay 186 voting aay the
motion
fails pending question is indefinitely
postp the pending question now is
indefinitely
postponement are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
representative maot requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is not it is not
sufficiently seconded this will be a
division
the motion before us inde depthly
postpone Senate Bill 537 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button of your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president opportunity to
vote 187 voting a 179 voting a Senate
postponed for what reason do a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to remove Senate
he
oh okay representative tki has requested
a roll call is as sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
C
the motion before us is to remove Senate
Bill 63 from the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
okay all members present had an
opportunity to vote house attend to
vote 185 voting a 180 voting a Senate
Bill
63 is remove from the table the pending
legislate are you ready for the question
a division has been
requested I would assume all members are
seats everybody all right the motion
before us is inexpedient to legislate on
Senate Bill 63 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red R button voting stations
all members present and an opportunity
vote 179 voting nay 187 voting nay the
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having voting Pro proce having
voted previously on the prevailing side
of this bill I ask for reconsideration
on the motion on the motion on the
motion of a to pass of motion ought to
pass please
okay so the motion before us now is
are you ready for the question all those
I I heard a division
oh uh the clerk heard a division I'm
vote seeing that everybody should still
be in their
seats the motion before us is
reconsideration on Senate Bill
63 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote how will attend to
vote 186 voting nay 180 voting nay the
motion
passes we're now back to to pass now
we're back to ought to pass on Senate
Bill
63 uh roll roll call has been requested
is so that sufficiently seconded I guess
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is aut to pass on
Senate Bill 63 this this is going to be
a roll call
vote if you're if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
represent
[Music]
RS all members present had an
opportunity to vote H will attain the
vote 186 voting a 180 voting a the
motion
no for what reason does a member rise m
speaker I move to take Senate Bill 563
off the table and ask for a roll call
vote
pass
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker having been informed that a
certain deadline may have passed I
withdrawn committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs to which
was referred Senate Bill
order relative to a voluntary home
visiting program report by the wellness
and primary prevention Council this
comes to us without recommendation sen
of toise moves ought to pass sen of
Amendment
1858 it's in your seat
Pockets chair recognizes representative
thank you Mr
Speaker good morning colleagues the
underlying bill here uh is to issue a
report um from a study conducted by the
wellness and primary prevention Council
um it's they're named in the original
Bill to do this study but they have some
voting members member organizations that
currently do and or may contract with
the state to provide home visiting
Services um therefore it's more
appropriate for this body to form a
legislative study committee to just
ensure that degree of separation and
impartiality um and to approach the
issue from a a stance of looking at what
resources are available now for home
visits and then asking the question of
is a robust centralized system for
voluntary home visits
needed um rather than starting from a
presumption that one is so I would uh if
you would please support the floor
Amendment thank
Weber thank you Mr
Speaker home visiting voluntary home
visiting before and after the birth of a
child is something that's been done for
decades and decades and decades and we
have lots and lots and lots lots of data
on how helpful it is for families to
strengthen families to promote the
health of the new infant to reassure new
moms and to give support to a new family
especially in those times and
places where they may not have family
members or other supports in the
community
the
amendment requires that we start from
scratch and
study the programs that
exist uh whether they who who's
delivering them how they're delivered
whether they're causing harm to families
or
not and it requires us to start again
with a study committee of legislators
who may or may not have expertise in the
subject
matter how much better would it be to
Simply start this
report with a committee that's already
established already
appointed
already
experts and have them take the data and
make a report
remember it's just a
report so that this body can then have
legislators consider the report and act
on it the members of the wellness and
primary prevention Council are a member
of the House the Senate member from
DHHS the Department of
Education The District Court the
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence Family Sport new Hampshire New
Hampshire children's trust and new
Futures please defeat the amendment
allow the experts to do their work and
then let the house get on with
submitted and I request a division vote
Mr Speaker chair recognize
thank you Mr Speaker my colleague is
right in the past number of decades the
government has been very involved in um
promoting more of these home visits but
for Millennia families and the
communities around them have been
involved in visiting with families when
a child is born a form family is formed
the blood family but larger the
community family is formed yes in recent
times we've moved away from supporting
our neighbors often times because
because we're so busy and we're doing so
many things and we expect that somebody
will step in and do our job for us
meanwhile we have grandmothers home
isolated from their children from their
grandchildren who are across the country
while another young family is bringing a
child into the world and their parent is
also far away rather than looking at
just our birth families we have our
opportunity to grow our community
families and bring this engagement
one of the determinants of health is
community involvement we have three
major life events that happen to us that
bring Community together birth marriage
and death birth is a source of creation
not just in the family and we should
ensure that as we look to where home
visiting is needed through the
government lens we're also looking at
what's happening the the committee would
look at duelist we would look at other
things where people are coming in as
part of the community and we would
acknowledge that there is more than just
the government who helps a family so
rather than going with an assumption
that we're going to continue down this
path of the government stepping in and
helping you with a family let's look
back to the Millennia about how we form
as humans how and importantly how we
form as a community to support each
other and make sure that we're not
shutting the door on that empty nester
down the street but inviting her over to
do some dishes have some coffee and hold
that baby please support the committee
Amendment
representative we Weber has requested a
division members take your
clear
the motion before us is floor of
amendment
1858 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Weber for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this amendment was
developed only yesterday and did not
have any kind of public hearing or
public input and if I know that it looks
to
me to be somewhat different from what I
just heard described would I vote no on
the amendment so we could vote on the
underlying Bill unamended thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
kushman for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that if this body is to endorse a study
to be done on voluntary home visiting
services that it should be one that is
impartial and comes from a position that
ensures it won't be biased and will be
done by the elected representatives of
the people would I now press the green
button and adopt this amendment thank
you the motion before us is floor
Amendment 1858 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppos or press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members presentent had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
184 voting a 181 voting a the amendment
is
adopted the question now is a to pass as
amended
division representative Weber has
requested that division members take
the motion before us is auto pass as
amended on Senate Bill 349 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button we opposed to
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all
right all members present and an
opportunity to vote how attend state to
the
vote 338 voting a 28 voting a committee
majority the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred Senate Bill 185 FN an
act establishing a committee to study
the various barriers to discharge for
patients to be sold safely discharged
from acute care facilities consider the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate Joe Alexander for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being agree
with the majority report the
recommendation Bill ought to pass Judy
Lanza for the minority of the committee
Lorenzo thank you Mr
Speaker s SP 185 establishes a committee
to study the various barriers to
discharge for patients to be safely
discharged from acute care facilities
the Genesis of this bill is that
initially the bill was entitled relative
to protective services for vulnerable
adults in the definition of Abandonment
and it appears there were proposals for
the bill to include Draconian penalties
for caregivers or family members who
quote abandoned their Wards or family
members which was just not practical nor
legal during the baate on SP 185 and the
other bod's committee hearings the
committee learned that there has been a
sharp increase in the number of
discharged patients who have no place to
go after
discharge at the same time there are a
number of adult patients waiting for
medical beds who cannot get beds for
these reasons the other body's Judiciary
Committee voted to retain
s SP 185 so that a study Community could
be
formed solving the issue of patients
ready for discharge with no place to go
is a top priority for New Hampshire
hospitals on any given day across the
state of New
Hampshire at least 100 patients that do
not need hospital care are stuck in a
hospital and occupy a bed for weeks and
sometimes months due to several reasons
that need to be resolved
olved barriers include lack of guidance
for patients who do not have
decisionmaking
capacity delays related to long-term
Medicaid
enrollment need for Specialized Care
such as one-on-one care substance use
disorder treatment and Behavioral Health
assistance patients have B at hospitals
by families and caregiv givers who no
longer have the capacity or resources to
continue to care for the the person at
home on the hospital side unnecessary
inpatient days cost millions of dollars
in unreimbursed acute care insurance
costs every year our hospitals face on
average 93%
occupancy Hospital vacancies eat Revenue
resulting in higher medical cost for
patients and higher insurance premiums
for our health care
consumers it is critical that our New
Hampshire hospital patients get the
level of care that they need to become
well without lingering in Li lingering
in limbo in an unneeded acute level care
of hospital or lingering in emergency
departments while waiting for an acute
level hospital bed that is why the
minority of this committee feels this
body should support a study committee on
Hospital efficiencies and Community
impacts on Health Care Mr Speaker please
press the red button to defeat the itl
so that another mission can be made
Alexander thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker s SP 185 adds to the exhaustive
list of study committees this
legislature has already passed
fortunately in this case there's a way
to save the legislature time and money
and the taxpayers money by voting itl in
the study committee the New Hampshire
Hospital Association states that they
need the study committee in order to fur
further study the barriers to Patient
discharge from the hospitals the
association also states that they are
aware of the barriers to discharge
patients including Medicaid enrollment
housing in security securing
Guardianship and the availability of
specialized services in this case a
legislative study committee is not
needed we already know what the barriers
are for for patients please vote green
the motion before inexpedient to
legislate on house Senate Bill
185 are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
motion before us is itl and Senate Bill
185 this is a division vote the chair
recognized representative L of for
parliamentary
inqu thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know there are barriers to patients
who are ready to be discharged from
acute care hospitals and Mr Speaker if I
know that these barriers include lack of
health insurance and a need for suitable
placement and Mr Speaker if I know that
the right thing to do is to establish a
study committee that would unlock
resources to help these Granite Staters
would you press the red button on the
itl motion so that another motion could
you chair recognize represent couta for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the New Hampshire
Hospital Association has already studied
what the barriers of discharging
patients are and if I know that those
same people who know what the problems
are are not even included on this
committee and and if I know that
legislators who want to work together
with the hospital Association on this to
try to resolve those barriers are more
than welcome to do so without this bill
then would I now press the red button
needed green button
sorry the motion before us majority
committee report of itl and Senate B 185
this a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you press the red button voting
speak
[Music]
represent
all members present have opportunity to
vote before I read that and everybody
starts running out of the room I'm
asking I'm requesting that all of you
stay in your
seats we're going to have a presentation
that could depend on your safety and
your colleague safety from the director
of uh Safety Services and that's going
to probably take maybe 10 12 minutes so
once I read the lunch uh announcements
we're going to go into recess and we're
going to have that presentation and
they're going to explain to you if we
have an emergency how to get out of here
and what to do so this could very well
hopefully it would never happen happens
and we never need it but this could
depend on your safety and your colleague
safety so I'm asking you to listen to
the presentation now I'll tend to state
of the
vote 188 voting yay 171 voting nay
announc we have three announcements
hello everyone we'll be brief we just
wanted to thank the members that were
able to join us on Monday for the
granite Bridge legislative Alliance
that's within the braver Angels
Consortium and that's really about
working together to find outside of
policy that we obviously disagree on are
there things we can agree on so that way
when we start to talk about policy maybe
that's a little more productive so we
had a wonderful meeting on Monday um we
look forward to hosting you at more
events and if you're interested you can
either contact representative PL or
myself and um we have the next thing we
have coming up is a baseball game and
representative corman's going to talk
about that in a minute I just say what
she
said Alicia Greg and I have developed a
working relationship we like each other
even though we disagree on some policy
that's
fine and you might have seen an email
from me about the Fisher Cats game on
Saturday Granite Bridge legislative
Alliance has bought several tickets for
the game uh the game's at 45 it's uh the
fisher cats but they will be playing as
the Manchester chicken tenders and
they're playing the Harrisburg other
sides of the wall because I can't say
the actual name uh tickets are
$12 uh they're really good seats right
behind the first base Dugout if you row
up
um and it's a great chance to show our
constituents that our political
differences end at the State House door
so if you're interested in coming to the
game please contact me Tom Corman find
me email me but I need a final headcount
by 5:00 today because any excess tickets
are going to be given to the Manchester
Boys and Girls Club but I hope that you
can join
Barry thank you Mr Speaker pursuant to
house rules I'm giving notice of the uh
house election law executive session to
be held at we have the thing so let's
say uh
11 53 uh in room 306 for bills cacr 22
and Senate Bill 534 thank you Kelly J
I just wanted to invite everybody to the
Society I'm requesting that everybody be
back in their seats
at
12:55 the house will be in recess and
right
e
a member
rise Mr Speaker I Rise to make a motion
that those gentlemen who wish to be
jackets the motion is for members men to
remove their jackets if you'd
like are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I eyes have it committing on Judiciary
to which was referred Senate Bill 413 FN
relative to civil elections for past
contamination comes without
recommendation Mr marjerie Smith moves
pass off and offers Amendment
23 chair recognized
representative
stab thank you Mr
speaker Mr Speaker I rise today in
opposition to Amendment
1678 this amendment is unre unrelated to
the underlying bill regarding civil
actions for pasas contamination which I
do support instead this amendment
inserts language on this underlying Bill
to reverse a longstanding protection for
New Hampshire renters and allows
landlords to evict tenants at the end of
their lease without giving any reason
regardless of whether they are up to-
date on their rent and they've followed
all the rules and conditions of their
lease this is not the first time we've
seen this previously most of the
testimony in favor of making this change
has revolved around a court case from
several decades ago today I would like
to reframe the debate and speak about it
in the context of our current 2020
rental market and the potential
ramifications for the
150,000 plus renter households in the
granite
state we're all aware that New Hampshire
has a critical shortage of housing units
both for purchase and rent we have
worked diligently this session to
identify potential solutions for this
vexing
problem this shortage has led to
escalating sale prices and rents the
average purchase price for a home in New
Hampshire is 520
$5,000 the average rent for a
two-bedroom apartment is
$1,900 the third highest in the country
the vacancy rate is
0.06% well below the 5% Target for a
balanced rental market for renters this
has most severely affected people who
don't earn much money or who are on
fixed
incomes if you make 80 to 100% of area
median income then there are 100 part
apartments in your price range for every
100 renters at 50% of Ami that number
drops to 66 affordable units per 100
people and at 30% which is a little
under $30,000 a year there are only 36
affordable apartments for every 100
households that need them of the people
in this lowest category 42% are senior
citizens 26% are disabled
the rest are mostly young people and
single- income workingclass
families ideally people should spend 30%
or less of their income for their
housing households that spend more are
considered cost burdened in New
Hampshire nearly half of all renters in
the state are cost
burdened many of the poorest people are
spending more than 50% of their income
on
housing renting today in this very tight
Market is not like it was 20 years ago
today you need to provide proof that you
make three times the amount of rent per
month a cost burden renters apartment
may have been affordable when they moved
in but now after years of escalating
rents they are no longer qualified to
live in their homes I spoke to one woman
in my district who saw her rent go up
$650 a month these people live in
constant fear of losing their homes
because if they do it will will be
nearly impossible to find another place
they are the ones who have turned to
food banks they are the ones who have
taken on second and third jobs in order
to pay the
rent that's enough data when I was on
the school board my superintendent used
to say data is great for giving you the
40,000 foot view but what you really
need to make a decision is to look at
the ground
truth so I'm going to give you some
ground truth about what really happens
to people who are in this situation let
me tell you about
Rachel who was here today with us in the
gallery she testified before the other
body on this
issue Rachel for years lived with her
family her husband and her granddaughter
in an apartment in Manchester they were
good tenants they paid their rent and
they made an effort to keep their place
nice unfortunately Rachel has a lot of
serious health problems and is on
disability as is her husband but
but they made it work somehow one day
their landlord told them that they
needed to move because he wanted to
renovate their apartment they were being
evicted though they had done nothing
wrong they had 30 days to find another
place Rachel got to work searching for
an apartment for them she'd see an
apartment for $1,500 a month it was
steep but she could make it work she'd
call the landlord or management company
and they'd ask her can you provide proof
that you make three times the rent
$4,500 a month sorry I can't then we
can't rent you this
apartment eventually they were evicted
and became homeless the stress caused
Rachel's husband to have a severe Health
setback they had to go to court they
moved into a hotel and in spite of her
best efforts it took two years for
Rachel to finally find an
apartment if we passed the this
amendment Rachel and her family could
find themselves in the exact same
situation when their lease ends and now
in addition to her financial constraints
she has an eviction on her record and
after three years it's not going to say
why she was
evicted so people will naturally assume
it was for non-payment of
rent Rachel's case is Not
Unusual every month 400 people in New
Hampshire are getting evicted mostly
because they have lost the battle
against Rising rents we need that number
to go down not up I ask only that we
don't choose to undermine the work that
we have been so focused on these last
two years and urge my colleagues to vote
no on this amendment thank you and I
request a roll call
Smith okay chair recognized
representative
ly thank you Mr
Speaker the bill from the other body
creates uh Express private right creates
an Express private right of action for
past contamination and also grants ex uh
expanded remedies it's basically a good
bill I think they could argue about is
it absolutely necessary I think there
there there could be an argument but I
think basically it's a good bill
the amendment adds to the bill the
substance of HB 1115 which this house
passed earlier this session after a
debate in which we basically considered
the same issues that were just uh that
were just addressed uh by the previous
speaker that's the hb1 1115 is the bill
that allows landlords to terminate a
lease at the end of the lease term it
has nothing to do with changing the law
about uh uh a renovation of property
being a grounds for eviction it is a
grounds for eviction it'll be a grounds
for eviction whether we pass this bill
or not this bill has really nothing to
do with that much of the argument you
heard really had talked about the you
know significant problems we have in the
housing market right now and there's no
dispute about that that's absolutely
true but what you didn't really hear is
how that AR how that relates to this
bill and why it makes sense
to say to have the law be that a
contract saying you have a contract for
a specific term means is enforcable by
the tenant but is not enforceable by the
landlord so that the tenant basically
can stay there as long as the tenant
wants it doesn't make any sense if any
sense frankly it's an embarrassment to
basic principles of contract law I would
note here that we passed hb1 11:15
earlier this year on a Division vote of
194 to 180 so it's very clear that the
bill had bipartisan
support the other body didn't agree with
the House's position and sent HB 1115 to
interim study sending this bill back to
the other body with with the amendment
uh including 1115 attached will make it
clear to the other body how important we
think it is for basic common sense and
basic contract principles to be restored
to law to landlord tenant law when faced
with the choice of losing the P bill
which the other body wants very badly or
accepting the principle that a lease
contract should mean what it says I
think we can be confident that the other
body will see the light and accept our
Amendment or at least ask for a
committee of conference for these
reasons I urge you to support the
amendment and Mr Speaker I would ask for
a division vote thank
you repr stab has asked for a roll call
is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is amendment
1678 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry um thank you very much if I know
if I know that the underlying bill is a
good one which um I'm sure
few of any of us would be opposed to but
if I know the um if I know the amendment
puts a uh puts an unrelated bill which
uh is not very popular in the other
side um other the wall would I uh vote
no in this amendment so then we can move
on and uh consider the underlying Bill
thank you chair recognized
enquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker if I
know that the other body really wants
this bill and if I know that this
amendment merely adds to the bill the
common sense leas the light regarding
the lease termination issue then would I
support this amendment by passing by
pressing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker motion before us is is amendment
1678 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press a green button of
your oppos press the red button voting
evil
[Music]
while members president have the
opportunity to vote house will tend to
vote 184 to 183
and the speaker did
vote question is now on the motion of
amended are you ready for the
question a division has been requested
everybody still should be in their seats
so the motion before us is aut to pass
that amended on Senate Bill 413 this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you press the red button voting
represent
rolds all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 188 voting a 78 voting a committee
adopted for what reason does member rise
Mr Speaker having voting on the
prevailing side I move reconsideration
of s SB 4113 and urge the body to vote
now
the motion is to reconsider Senate Bill
413 a division has been requested Meers
the motion before us is to reconsider
Senate Bill 413 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
suppress the red button voting stations
[Music]
all members present had the opportunity
vote 177 voting a 188 voting aay the
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred Senate Bill 422 changing
several references and modifying
language in Parental and birth
records it comes without recommendation
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion State your motion I move
move to table SB 422 and I request a
division vote the motion is to table
Senate Bill
422 and a division has been requested
do
motion before us to table Senate Bill
422 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognized representative drive
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill represents
massive change to vocabulary related to
marriage and parentage including those
endearing new terms gestational carrier
and other non-birth parent and if I know
that an 8 page 83 subsection touching
change is too large and too important to
rush would I now press the green button
to table this Bill thank
you chair recognize rep repres
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill makes important
changes to Parenting and the birth
records legislation that would for
example uh eliminate the need for uh in
in uh in vitro fertilization situations
for for parents to go to court uh to
have to get have necessary uh Records
changed and if I know that the amendment
to this uh that the that one of the
amendments to this bill passed the
committee on a 20 to0 the Judiciary
Committee on a 20 to0 basis and if I
know that another amendment that would
be discussed if we debated the bill
would would reinforce positions already
taken by the house on two earlier bills
that were passed then would I press the
red button and vote against the motion
to table so that we can have a thorough
debate on the bill thank you Mr Speaker
and iqu a division
vote the motion before us is the table
Senate Bill 422 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
all members present had an opportunity
vote 136 voting y
fails representative margerie Smith
moves ought to pass and offers
Amendment
16978 printed in house record 18 Pages
23 through 32 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say the division has been
requested
the motion before us is amendment 1697 H
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposer press the red button
[Music]
eating
for
all members pres opportunity to vote
houseold tend to State the
vote 337 voting yay 28 voting nay the
amendment
passes bills on second reading open to
further Amendment representative
Alexander moves Amendment
1698 H printed in houseal record 18 page
32-
stab there STS waves
thank you Mr Speaker Amendment 1698 H is
effectively the same as
s422 with uh Amendment 1697 that our
body um just approved by a wide margin
uh but with the text of two unrelated
bills um in it which do not enjoy such
wide support uh one uh essentially is
moot at this point uh HB 11:15 because
it was incorporated into the previous
bill that we just um voted up with that
Amendment um the
other Bill uh is HB 1412 relative to
licensing of court reporters um that was
also added uh also an unrelated bill
that came to the floor with no
recommendation from our Judiciary
Committee and was unanimously recom
amended for itl by the body behind the
wall behind me
um there was no stated um opposition to
the continued licensing of court
reporters uh during our committee
hearings everyone who's covered by the
licensing uh even though they had to pay
and go through requirements continued to
um push to maintain that licensing
provision so hope that we would keep
that um so I will say the body uh also
behind the wall behind me um has a habit
of sending us back bills that we support
loaded with unrelated Provisions with
less support in this uh chamber uh
that's not an approach that um I feel we
should embrace here in the house I'd
like uh to allow us to pass this bill
cleanly with the content that we
basically all agree on I believe uh urge
the members of this body to vote no on
this
amendment I ask for recogniz
representative
alander thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I rise in favor of amendment 20246 98h
this simple amendment is a carbon copy
of the amendment the house just passed
and adds two simple bills to reassert
our house position the first bill would
help alleviate the housing crisis by
adding more flexibility in the housing
market the House pass HB 11115 would
enable landlord and tenants to have
creative conversations about lease
agreements this amendment would reward
good behavior from tenants and penalize
bad behavior additionally this amendment
would add hb1 1412 which repeals court
reporter certifications this outdated
and unneeded certification cost $300 and
reputable court reporters already have
to be involved in National organizations
such as the national court reporters
Association in order to receive jobs
whether you are in favor of the
underlying bill or not I encourage you
to vote in favor of this amendment to
send a message to the body on the other
side of the wall that the house would
like them to look favorably on these
bills thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is
amendment
16988 a division has been requested
motion before us is amendment 698 H this
is a division vote chair recognize
iny thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that voluntary legal
Declaration of parentage of a child born
to an unmarried couple is one of the
most meaningful acts that one can
undertake to establish their rights and
responsibilities for raising that child
and if I know that the language in the
current RSA which provides this option
only to a quote father wishing to
establish quote
paternity is outdated and fails to
recognize the structure of many New
Hampshire families in which the
non-birth parent is not a male and if I
know that this bill doesn't change who
can be a parent in New Hampshire but
rather who can legally declare their
parentage without going through a formal
adoption procedure in court then would I
press the green button to bring this New
Hampshire statute up to date and into
alignment with the reality of family
structures in our
red chair recognize representative Lyn
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this is another bill that of the
least termination Bill previously
discussed and the court reporter
deregulation Bill both of which were
previously passed by this house and if I
know that adding this this amendment
will once again demonstrate to the other
body that we strongly support the
measures we have passed and will once
again cause the other body to
re-evaluate its position concerning our
bills then would I support this
amendment by pressing the green button
thank you very much Mr Speaker motion
before us is amendment 1698 H this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposer
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
okay
all members present have an opportunity
vote 191 voting aay 183 voting aay the
motion
fails now we're back to ought to
speak
have we have no debate left that
Amendment failed so we have no
debate question is now on pass is
amended on the question for what reason
does a member arise Mr Speaker I move to
422 Motion in order motion is in order
to inde inde definitely postpone Senate
Bill
422 move
table motion is a higher priority motion
to table is a higher priority so now we
422 and we have a request for a division
the motion before us is the table seter
bill 422 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your poer press the red button
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 179 voting aay 186 voting n the
motion
fails that appending question now is
indefinitely
postponed I expected that Meers are in
their seats this is a division vote
everybody should be in their
seats if you're
in if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 187 voting a 178 voting a Senate
postponed the majority committee on
Judiciary to which was referred Senate
Bill
462 an act relative to raising the cap
on Damages for r wrongful death loss of
Consortium claims consider that say and
Report the same with the recommendation
Bill ought to pass Senator Ben Ming for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation that the B Bill be
referred for interim study sen Richard
trip for the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I move to indefinitely postpone
the motion is to indefinitely postpone
Senate Bill
462 order the motion is in order a
division has been requested members take
the motion before us is indefinitely
postpone Senate Bill 462 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
representative Lyn for a parliamentary
inqu
thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker if I
know that excuse me that this Bill H is
is simply not ready for prime time and
the most efficient way to deal with it
right now is to indefinitely postpone it
would I press the green button to do
just that thank you Mr Speaker and I
request a division vote do I recognize
representative margerie Smith for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I was
under the impression
perhaps incorrectly that the
legislators were elected to legislate to
debate bills and then vote on them would
I vote against indefinitely postpone so
that we can hear what the factors are in
this bill and then make a legislative
decision thank you the motion before us
inde defly postpone Senate Bill 462 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
opposer press the red button voting
[Music]
representative leus representative leus
representative
all members pres an opportunity to vote
vote 175 voting a 187 voting a the
motion
fails now we're back to the original
motion of art to pass on Senate Bill 462
hunt thank you Mr Speaker I promise to
be
brief I was reading the blurb the other
day and it talks about whether this is
going to have an impact on insurance
premiums or
not as someone who served on the
insurance committee for over 30 years
there's a couple of things I can
guarantee you and a couple of things
I'll tell you have a high probability of
happening number
one I guarantee
you
everyone's insurance will be
impacted the simple reason being that
the person the
underwriter who issues your policy who
is doing setting up your policy cannot
ignore these
numbers these numbers are off the
chart and I would say that if it had
gone to a different committee they would
have come back with much more reasonable
numbers but it didn't I'm not I'm very
respectful for other committees and what
their work but in this case these
numbers are way way way too
high I guarantee you everyone who has an
insurance policy will see an
business that has a vehicle or heavy
equipment is going to see a Whopper of
an
increase the only other thing I will
will not try to guarantee this but I can
promise you
this there will be some insurance
companies that will pull out of this
state if we pass these
numbers stay far and pulled out of
California insurance we have a very
Lively Insurance market and the last
thing we need to do is up that upset
that cart with these outrageous numbers
please do not pass this bill put it in
an interim study and yes we can make
sure that the department does an
Actuarial study and give us numbers that
really make sense please vote
no your recognized representative
Christine
Barz thank you thank you Mr Speaker
let's talk about the facts not
hypotheticals in the Senate here in in
February 6th those representing the
insurance interest were asked in other
states with this type of statue did
insurance rates go up they did not have
the answers to that the bill passed in
the senate committee ought to pass then
it went on to pass in the Senate
17-7
42424 it comes to Judiciary 11 weeks and
one day day
later at that hearing the same question
was asked of the insurance
companies we don't have that answer yet
they had 11 weeks in one day to get that
answer in Illinois in
2007 they had put this into effect in
2010 they caps were eliminated in
according to the American Medical ass
Association in a 9-year study from 2009
to
2018 malpractice
insurance
dropped in
OBGYN malpractice insurance dropped in
general surgery and malpractice
insurance in internal methods increased
by an average of
$139 a year Maine
changes their changes from
2019 went from 500,000 to
750,000 since um that was in 2000 yet
since those rates since that happened
their rates went up
2.79% and the national average for rates
2.77% New Hampshire has the lowest caps
on recovery of grief sorrow and mental
suffering and wrongful death in the
country Vermont and Maine have no caps
Main's was just injested for inflation
in 2003 to $1 million cap Rhode Island
raised its cap to 3,5
350,000 in 2003 as well our cap has not
been adjusted in 20 5 years inflation
alone would bring it up to
300,000 but let's bring it up so that we
don't have to bring this up again yet
New Hampshire insurance companies are
making record profits the top 10
casualty companies in the state had an
average loss ratio of
56% meaning payout of only 56 cents on
every premium dollar that they take in
insurance companies have doubled their
profits since 2022 to
2023 yet a mother who is not working who
does not have a degree who is killed
might not receive damages for lost
earnings since she is the sole has the
sole honorable job of being a wife and a
mother doesn't her family deserve
compensation ation for their loss of her
their grief their sorrow and wrongful
death separate from damages I work for
the people I do not work for insurance
companies thank
thank you Mr
chair oh Mr
speaker thank you Mr
Speaker this is an interesting Bill we
spent two and a half hours listening to
uh
uh everyone say well we don't know if
this is too much to raise the the the uh
cap or if if the uh raising the cap
would raise the insurance rates this
bill originally was determined to be uh
sent to interim study I think that if we
couldn't figure out what was going on in
two and a half hours then uh sending to
interim study would give us a chance to
figure out which
the proper amount should be for the cap
on wrongful death for loss of Consortium
and possibly get an actuarium study so
that we could find out what would
actually happen to the uh
uh uh insurance rates
so I ask you to vote red to fail the OTP
thank
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
state of New Hampshire places a cap on
insurance claims for loss of Consortium
due to the wrongful death of a spouse
parent or child these claims arise
through a deceased person's estate where
its administrator can bring claims that
due to the negligence of another this
close family relationship was severed
and the spouse child or parent should be
compensated for the loss of that
relation
relationship as a state we value the
loss of a spouse at
$150,000 and only
$50,000 for a parent or
child if those values sound low it may
be due to the fact that they haven't
been adjusted since they were instated
in the late '90s the change that s SP
462 proposes is a more than reasonable
limit of $500,000 for the loss of a
spouse and a three $300,000 limit for
the loss of a parent or
child and those numbers represent a
compromise within the other legislative
body with the original version of the
bill propose proposing an elimination of
those
caps removing the limit on loss of
Consortium damages alt together may
sound like a big step but we don't have
to look outside of New England for
examples of what happens when these
completely arbitrary caps are
removed the answer is nothing insurance
is no less affordable in the absence of
these limits the only other state in New
England that even has these limits is
Maine and their cap on loss of
Consortium damages is a million
dollars the people in those States
continue to have insurance and the
insurance companies haven't
left and why is
that these types of claims aren't common
and they're not common because they're
expensive to litigate when they do
happen New Hampshire jurries don't give
EX excessive verdicts which we know
because UNCA damages exist for other
claims in New Hampshire and there are no
numbers to show that excessive verdicts
occur in those circumstances with any
frequency not only that judges have the
power to reduce excessive monetary
verdicts if one were to
occur and although we aren't voting on
an unlimited cap on Damages for loss of
Consortium due to the negligent
causation of death we should consider
that in New Hampshire damages are
uncapped for certain types of negligent
injury we are quite literally saying
there are some things in life that are
worse than death but it's not the loss
of a spouse parent or
child this is a weighty issue and the
types of families that would rely on
this RSA and the change that s SP 462
would make to it need
this they've lost their spouse their
parent or their child and our laws have
defined a completely inadequate value of
a relationship that will never exist
again please support the current motion
and committee recommendation of oop pass
thank you Mr Speaker and I request a
division
vote representative Lynn has requested a
motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill
462 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Lynn for
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the increase in loss of
Consortium caps in this bill are far
above what the Caps would be if a mere
inflation or Consumer Price Index were
applied to the original caps as enacted
in the late 1990s and if I know that
this bill is opposed by the insurance
industry the New Hampshire Hospital
Association the New Hampshire
Association of counties and perhaps most
significantly the New Hampshire
insurance department and if I know that
the basis of these groups opposition is
the concern that the damage caps will
have the increase in damage caps will
have on insurance rates which are
already under great stress and more
importantly on the availability of
insurance for certain critical uh
professions such as doctors and other
medical professionals and finally if I
know that much of these concerns could
be eliminated if the insurance
department is given time to conduct an
Actuarial study of this proposal and and
that that we have no indication that 11
weeks would be an would be a sufficient
time to conduct such a study or that
back in February the insurance
department was simply able to drop
everything to start one right away then
would I oppose the OTP motion so that a
motion for interim study can be made and
the proposal can be brought back next
Speaker jerich and ie representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that I agree
completely with the chair of the
Judiciary Committee when he talks about
the fact that for some reason reason the
department of insurance has been unable
or unwilling to give us the data that
could help inform us on what would
happen in New Hampshire but if I also
know that without New Hampshire figures
we would best look at what happens in
all the other states that have uh raised
their limits and found that in no other
state has there been an increase in
rates if I know that the rates in um all
other states in New England uh H have no
cap except for Maine where the value has
gone up and where there has been no
increase in rates and if I also know
that because I value a successful um
capitalist system I'm pleased to be able
to report that insurers in New Hampshire
are doing very
well um could I now bring myself to
recognize that in order to be respectful
to the
families in New Hampshire who find
themselves in this
situation that I would vote in fact to
increase the Caps put us in line with
all of the other states that have done
this without facing any situation with
the sky falling and therefore vote ought
to pass thank
you motion before a majority committee
report of a to pass mon sen B
462 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposal you press the red button
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state to
the
vote 191 voting aay 174 voting aay
for what reason is member rise Mr
Speaker I'd like to request that the
debate on Senate Bill 462 be placed in
the permanent
objection majority Commission on
Judiciary to which was refer Senate Bill
507 FN act extending the time to
petition for a new trial in certain
cases consider the same report the same
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim
study sen of Caitlyn katab for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass Zoe Manos for the minority
of the committee chair recognizes
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to speak
against the motion of vendim study on
this bill currently a criminal defendant
may not challenge a conviction after
three years for any reason this bill
provides a narrow exception from the
three-year cap on filing a motion for a
new trial the conditions are if but only
if there's newly discovered evidence new
or additional forensic testing or new
scientific understanding that would have
been material for the
FactFinder if all the evidence was
available at the time of trial and there
is no new forensic testing available or
no new scientific understanding then the
three year cap still
applies you will hear questions about
whether habius Corpus is applicable in
these cases habus Corpus which is known
as the great RIT dates back to the Magna
Carta it literally means let us have the
body it is a Judicial command to the
Jailer to bring the prisoner before the
Court habus Corpus is not available
unless the defendant is imprisoned or
subject to limitations on his Liberty
such as parole or
probation this bill is broader than hius
Corpus it applies to defendants both
imprisoned and those whose Liberty have
been
restricted habius Corpus is not sub is
not a subject of this bill and it would
not be proper to include it in interim
study habius Corpus should be left to
Future
legislation you will also hear concerns
about the application of the DNA statute
once again that statute is only
available to defendants who are
imprisoned or who have other
restrictions on their Liberty and it is
only applicable in cases in which
biological material that can be tested
for DNA is
available there are cases in which there
is no DNA
DNA material no biological material that
can be tested if the DNA statute is
applicable then the courts will apply
it finally you will hear concerns about
criminal defendants potentially filing
repeated motions for a new trial however
our Superior Court judges are very
capable of reviewing these petitions
they will sort out those that have Merit
and deserve a hearing from those that
have done and should be outright
denied remember the law holds that it is
better that 10 guilty persons Escape
than that one innocent
suffer Innocents cannot wait people have
been convicted of crimes they did not
commit in the narrow circumstances of
this bill criminal defendants should
have a path forward to prove their
innocence please vote no on interim
study so that another motion can be made
Mr Speaker I request a division vote
thank
you representative cab recogniz speak
report thank you Mr Speaker this bill
would extend the time to petition the
court for a new trial from three years
to indefinitely for any criminal
conviction for a felony offense or Class
A misdemeanor if new evidence is
discovered of course we don't want an
innocent person to be
incarcerated however there are already
existing Protections in place such as
habius Corpus so there really is no need
to rush this law and potentially
traumatize victims with frivolous
petitions due to the inadequate language
this is a very important issue and it is
critical that we study it to get the
language right the first time as written
no parameters exist such as language to
address successive petitions on the same
grounds nor any outer limit on how soon
after new evidence is discovered that
one must petition the court
comparatively the postconviction
Bill 507 a division vote has been
EXP
seats the questions on the committee
report of interm study on Senate Bill
507 and this is division vote
representative Ming is recognized for
parliamentary
correct thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would not be
granting a new trial based on newly
discovered evidence or new scientific
understanding and if I know that it
would only allow a person to ask for a
new trial then wouldn't I oppose the
current motion for interim study by
pushing the red button so a better
motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker representative Linds recognized
inir thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that this bill is not ready for
prime time because it leaves many
important issues unaddressed and if I
know that among these issues are the
absence of limits on successive motions
for new trial raising the same issues
the lack of any threshold requirement to
make some level of showing that the
motion for new trial has has a merit and
is likely to succeed and finally if I
know that there is no urgency to act
immediately to expand the three-year
time limit on motions for new trial
because in almost not all not all but
almost all cases an alternative remedy
is available through a petition for rid
of avius Corpus then would I support the
interim study motion by pressing the
green button so that the deficiencies I
have noted can be addressed and the bill
brought back next year thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the committee
report of inum study this is a division
vote if you are in favor press the green
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 172 in the affirmative 182 in the
negative the motion fails representative
Manos moves ought to pass the bills on
second reading and open a further
Amendment representative cab moves floor
Amendment 1857 H which can be found in
your seat pockets and recognized speak
motion thank you Mr
Speaker this floor Amendment addresses a
few of the issues that were mentioned
one being that it provides
that it can't just be any evidence you
have to establish that there would be a
reasonable likelihood of a more
favorable outcome two it also defines
I think it's
important that we're following the right
standards for that it also further
defines the fact that a court need not
entertain a repetitive petition that has
already been ruled against the first
time otherwise if we don't put this in
somebody could literally just keep
petitioning the same time over and over
again on the same grounds that have
already been
found against so I think this is a
really important amendment that we
passed and I ask you all to please vote
in favor of it thank
you representative margerie Smith
amendment Mr Speaker I Rise Against um
the floor Amendment the floor amendment
was never presented to the Judiciary
Committee even though we have had this
me you recognize to speak against the
floor Amendment that's what I'm doing is
that all good okay thank you I just want
to make sure I'm doing the right thing I
always try to do the right thing um and
mostly
succeed um the amendment the floor
Amendment was never presented to the
members of the Judiciary Committee even
though we have had this bill for quite a
while it was never reviewed by us it was
never evaluated by the committee and we
in this legislature like to rely on
committees to do the heavy
lifting uh the changes that the floor
amendment has
included um seem to confuse rather than
clarify
issues for example it refers to DNA and
yet while DNA is important it is by no
means the only set of circumstances that
could change um over time and where it
might be appropriate in order to make
sure that the right decisions are made
to consider other factors all of this um
uh is I think important but what strikes
me most is the language in the amendment
which seems to think that the judicial
branch is not on its own capable of
determining how to process petitions
that come to the court and that the
legislature should interfere with how
the judicial branch processes those
cases I'm sure that the amendment was
well-meaning but I don't think it helps
us achieve the goals that this committee
this legislature has just indicated that
it has some support for so I ask you to
vote down the floor Amendment so that we
can then Vote or to pass on the bill
Speaker the questions on the adoption of
floor Amendment 1857 H ready for the
question thought so this will be a
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment 1857 H representative Ming is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if if I know that the floor Amendment
will create a more burdensome standard
for simply asking for a new trial based
on newly discovered evidence or a new
scientific understanding then wouldn't I
oppose the floor amendment by pushing
the red button thank you Mr
Speaker representative Linds recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if if I know that the amendment here
corrects a number of the deficiencies in
the bill that we that were previously uh
referenced would I then support this
amendment by pressing the green button
thank you Mr
Speaker questions on the adoption of
floor Amendment 1857 H it's a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
[Music]
how all members pres had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to the state
of the
vote 179 in the affirmative 181 and
negative the amendment
fails question now is on a to pass on
Senate Bill
57 are you ready for the
question division vote members back in
your seats you almost made
on
the questions on the motion V to pass on
Senate Bill 507 this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
repr
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attended
the state of the vote 190 in the
affirmative 170 and then negative the
motion's
adopted the majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which was referred Senate
Bill
576 an act relative to reporting the
death of Voters having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is in
expedient to legislate representative
margerie Smith for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having been consider the same being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill a
you pass representative Joe Alexander
committee representative cab is
recognized speak against the committee
report
thank th will come to order let's be
able to hear her continue thank you Mr
Speaker it is often said that we can be
assured of two things death and
taxes it is the former topic on which I
speak today sp sp 567 has to do with the
somber subject of someone who has passed
away in other words someone who is no
more has ceased to be and is Rift of
Life current legislation requires that
when the city or town receives an
official notice of death that the
supervisors of the checklist be notified
to remove that individual from the voter
roles this bill then has the executive
or a personal representative notify the
local Clerk of the death of an
individual 18 years of age and above
within a 30-day
period if you'll pardon the expression
it creates a
deadline you may ask ask what about a
grieving widow or a relative what if
they forget well no penalty is
associated with this bill so such an
understandable admission would not be
punished this bill simply expedites the
notification process particularly for
lawyers and estate fiduciaries handling
such matters this bill helps to keep the
voter rules clean it helps with the
Integrity of our New Hampshire elections
and with voter conf confidence honorable
colleagues I'd be grateful for your
you representative Mark Pages recognizes
report thank you Mr Speaker today I Rise
to support the majority recommendation
to itl SP
576 this bill a bill that would require
an executive of an estate to report to
the clerk the death of a person within
30 days of being appointed as executive
is the classic case of a solution
searching for a
problem don't take it from me though the
Secretary of State's office gave
extensive testimony and in fact was the
only one to speak to the substance of
the bill at the house hearing expressing
concerns concluding ultimately the bill
was unnecessary for any number of
reasons the Department of Health and
Human Services town and City Clerks
among others share that
position first as the Secretary of State
reported there's already a robust and
thorough coordinated system in place to
ensure that a deceased person is timely
removed from the voting roles and it's
working Secretary of State could not
recall a single instance of any problem
that the bill would have resolved second
as the Secretary of State office also
noted existing criminal penalties
effectively deter anyone who might
consider committing voting fraud voter
fraud by requesting an absentee ballot
of a deceased person penalties for
election interference are quite severe
as they should be and they're working
and third and finally implementation of
this bill is unclear the bill does not
contain any information about how or who
is to notify the executive of this Duty
and there's no enforcement
mechanism not only is the bill a
solution in search of a problem but it's
those of us Mr Speaker when I die I want
to be buried in Chicago so I can keep
voting now various Geographic locations
have been used and substituted for
Chicago like Louisiana and Texas but
I've never heard New Hampshire mention
in that joke and I know why the current
system works and passing s SP 576 would
only create a problem not resolve one I
urge you to vote in favor favor of the
Speaker the motion is in expedience to
576 as the previous speaker will you
take a question nope okay he doesn't
yield so anyway the Motions in expedient
to legislate representative Sweeney
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
that is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
a
questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
and this is a roll call
vote representative Wallace is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that a ricent New Hampshire
voter that dies out of state there is no
procedure for that person to be removed
from the voter checklist and Mr Speaker
if I know that there is a proced
procedure to remove the decedent from
the checklist only if they die in New
Hampshire and lastly Mr Speaker if I
know that there is no legitimate reason
to keep a decedent's name on the voter
checklist would to now press the red
button so a better motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker representative
inquir
right Mr Speaker if I know that the the
current process of reporting death of
Voters already provides many levels of
assurance and if I know that creating a
new law to add an Executor an executive
or personal representative of the estate
to this process would be burdensome to
all parties
involved then when I press the green
button to itl this needless motion to a
problem that does not exist because
unlike Hol would over there is fear of
Bad actors I don't see dead people
Speaker the also will come to order I'm
going break this Hammer one of these
days the questions on the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislate and that's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote which
includes
fails
represent representative Alexander moves
for what reason does the member rise Mr
Speaker I move to table this
bill priority representative margerie
Smith moves to lay Senate Bill 576 on
the
table representative Sweeney requests a
roll call this is getting exciting are
you
ready and it's sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
all right the question is whether to lay
Senate Bill 576 on the table
representative margorie Smith recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that dead people don't vote
and if I
know and if I know that everyone in
Authority from town clerks to the uh
Secretary of State to the health
department opposes this legislation
would I now vote to table the Bill thank
you representative Alexander's
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know this problem does exist because a
member of our committee testified to
having a dead person voting absentee in
the First Nation primary would I vote
red so we could pass this election
Integrity Bill thank
you we're in the voting
mode members will be in their seats
we're in the voting mode members will be
in their seats
now
bye
go the question is whether lay Senate
Bill 576 on the table and it is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
[Music]
speak have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend the
state of the vote which does not include
my
vote 18 180 in the affirmative 181 in
now we're on the question of ought to
pass for what reason does the member
rise point of personal privilege I'm
sorry what I think no what wait this the
secretary
the the clerk will tell me what I can
to
respond representative margerie Smith
recognized to speak against the
motion thank thank you very much I'm
always happy to have the clerk advise me
um I am going to speak against the
motion of ought to pass for all the
reasons that I have already given you um
based on substance but I am going to add
one additional comment a statement was
made by uh one of our colleagues about a
comment that was made
casually in the Judiciary Committee in
fact the comment said something about of
a person having voted and then died
before the election
in fact that is true a person
voted filed the ballot and died and as
always happens and is appropriate to
happen the clerk of the jurisdiction
where that person had resided did not
count the ballot because it had been
recorded that that person had died the
system works to pretend that it doesn't
work and to make a fuss about something
that isn't accurate isn't helpful and I
hope that you will vote against or to
much questions on the motion about to
pass on Senate Bill
representative Sweeney request a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
this will be a roll call vote members
in
questions on the motion of V to pass on
signate Bill 576 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
[Music]
of all members presentence and an
opportunity to vote the house attend to
the state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 180 in the
majority of the committee the house will
Rise um Mr Speaker I think I'm rising
because it's a habit I'm sorry about
that but um I would like to um
move
reconsideration on SB
no all right the motion I have a
division
please the motion before us is
reconsideration on Senate Bill 46 62 a
division has been requested members take
the motion before us is reconsideration
on Senate bill for 462 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members present have an opportunity
vote 162 voting aay 197 voting aay the
motion
failed majority of committee on
Municipal and County government to
wishes referred Senate Bill 383 FN
relative to local tax GS having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment recommendation
to Bill ought to pass with Amendment s
of Diane power from majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree majority Report with the
following resolution that is inexpedient
to legislate representative Jim magori
for the minority of the committee the
amendment is 152 printed in house record
18 page
23 are you ready for the question on on
the amendment all those a division has
been
the motion before us is amendment 1528 H
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button your
opposer press the red button voting
[Music]
representative
L while members president an opportunity
vote 182 voting a 176 voting a the
amendment passes the motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment
Gilman thank you Mr
Speaker this bill would amend an
enabling RSA adding a tax C
calculation option for municipalities
and school
districts currently caps are defined by
a specific dollar amount of increase or
a budget percentage increase as agreed
upon by the
voters given that only 13 municipalities
Andor school
districts about 3% of political
subdivisions have adopted local tax caps
and eight communities rejected such me
measure just this year tax caps are
clearly not a popular budgetary
tool Municipal and school budgets
include line items that can't be zeroed
out buildings still need to be heated
and maintained electricity supplied
Vehicles fueled software technology
media tools and remote infrastructure
basic staff health care costs which are
fully the burden of the
taxpayer and pay
ions basic services such as police and
fire and plowing and Road repair costs
need to be provided for some of these
can be deferred but eventually they have
to be done and the longer the wait the
more expensive the job is to
do this bill offers an actual
mathematical equation to calculate a tax
cap it uses the previous year's budget
the change year over year of the
enrollment and I'm sorry and a
multiplier for
inflation School enrollment enrollment
is computed using the department of
education's average daily membership in
admr and this is the membership of the
school district as of October 1st of of
the prior
year the CPI is that of January 1st of
some undefined year and the same educ
equation is used for both the municipal
and school
budgets or uh sorry with the town
population or the student
admi are but there's no mechanism for
choosing which value value to
use the department of Education advises
this bill needs to define the admr to be
specific as to what grades are covered
our education Freedom account
participates participants included our
students residing residing in one town
but tuition to a school in another town
included are Charter Schools
included are preschools
included the Department of Education
apparently has different admr
calculations for different purposes
and is concerned of unintended
consequences if other rsas can be
avoided by clarifying the choice of the
admr definition used
here for school budgets unavoidable
costs include those mentioned for the
municipal budget but add on the cost of
maintaining 14 areas of Education
competencies for high school
graduation staff such as counselors and
special need support are required ired
by the state federal law and the
Department of Education rules so what
can be changed if a proposed school
budget exceeds the cap staff hiring
freezes books class sizes maintenance
deferral after school programs class
trips to the State House Sports chorus
advanced placement C
courses what has already been reduced
before in studing a school tax cap our
Revenue to the education fund such as
the business profits tax and the
business Enterprise
tax tying a tax cap to the Consumer
Price Index and populations may seem
like a logical way to control spending
while counting for inflation in good
years if populations increase and
inflation increases or the calculation
reaches a break even Point by adopting
the C
calculation in this bill it commits
towns and schools
to contend with the opposite results
when a deflation occurs a negative
inflation rate is
applied during such recessions
businesses close people leave lose jobs
and leave town to find work but we'll
still need to
provide the basic Services adequate
education and the buildings that house
the services we need to maintain at some
level another point is that the CPI
doesn't account for for the cost of fuel
or other energy components as these are
highly
volatile and remember not too long ago
when the fuel prices
skyrocketed towns struggled to keep
Cloud trucks running and schools warm
within the budgets that had been passed
under this bill's optional calculations
and these circumstances local budgets
could not sustain the
services s SP 383 optional multip is
creative but poses a higher risk to
towns and schools hedging their bets on
populations and cpis that we can't
control so Mr Speaker I ask you to join
me and the 97% of the state's political
sub subdivisions that reject in any form
a tax cap and please vote against the
motion of ought to pass as amended thank
you Mr
power thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of the motion ought to pass with
Amendment on Senate Bill
383 Mr Speaker year after year our
constituents are faced with ever
increasing local budgets this trend
results in escalating property taxes
which are simply unsustainable for
taxpayers
Senate Bill 383 is important enabling
legislation that provides towns and
school districts with two optional
budgetary tools which can be adopted
locally and used to better manage local
spending in a fiscally responsible
manner first this bill adds an
adjustment method to the existing local
tax cap enabling statute currently the
prop proposed tax effort can be capped
by either a fixed percentage or a fixed
dollar amount this bill adds a third
option by which the proposed tax effort
can be capped based on both a given
annual inflation index and the change in
population of the town or the school
district where the annual inflation
index is one published by the US Bureau
of Labor Statistics or is specified as
the municipal cost index published by
American city and county for towns and
Village districts the population is
calculated by the Department of Business
and economic Affairs and for school
districts the population is the average
daily membership in residents admr
reported to the Department of Education
notably a three-fifth super majority
vote required to either adopt or resend
a local tax cap and the ability to
override the tax cap each year by a
simple majority vote of the legislative
body is unchanged by this bill and
second this bill also provides for a new
optional School District budget cap this
new provision is also enabling
legislation that establishes an annual
cap on proposed spending the School
District budget cap is based on a
current per per pupil cost times the
number of pupils that is the average
daily membership in residents where the
current pupil cost is adjusted annually
based on a selected inflation index
again reported by the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics or the municipal cost index
finally similar to the local tax cap the
new School District budget cap is
adopted or rescinded by a 3- fifth super
majority vote and in each year the
School District budget cap can be
overridden by a 3- fifths super majority
vote of the legislative body to conclude
Senate Bill 383 is important enabling
legislation that provides taxpayers with
an additional practical tax effort
adjustment method under the existing
local tax cap RSA and it establishes a
new School District budget cap statute
both of which automatically adjust with
inflation as well as population changes
within the town or the school district
encouraging fiscally responsible
budgeting and also gives Granite State P
taxpayers the means by which they can
more effectively manage local spending
in in an effort to keep local property
taxes under control for these reasons I
urge my fellow colleagues to support the
committee recommendation of ought to
pass with amendment by voting yes on
Senate Bill 38 58 wait
383 yes 383 and I ask for a division
vote thank you Mr
Speaker representa Sweeny has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us majority committee
report of Auto passes amended on Senate
Bill 383 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative mangi for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know this B this bill imposes two State
imposed mandates which erode local
control to set your local tax caps and
Mr Speaker if I know that the existing
Provisions for ex establishing tax caps
have not been challenged and therefore
adding a confusing option is
unnecessary and Mr Speaker if I also
know the state imposed formula in this
bill for calculating the tax cap
requires using the average daily
membership in residents but according to
the Department of Education there are
several definitions of admr and without
a clear definition of which to use the
formula will not be accurate and there
be made there may be unintended
consequences for several other sections
of law then Mr Speaker would I vote
against the majority committee report by
pressing the red button so that another
motion can be made which will preserve
local control for local taxes and local
spending thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Osborne for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh if I
know that this bill provides towns and
school districts with an additional
option not a mandate to responsibly
propose budgets that track with
inflation and population changes and if
I know that when local spending is
fiscally responsible that property taxes
will be sustainable for our constituents
would I now press the green button uh to
support the committee
recommendation the motion before us
majority committee report of Auto passes
amended on Senate Bill 383 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
representative
all members present had the opportunity
vote 184 voting a 177 voting 80
committee on Municipal and County
government to issu the for Senate Bill
532 FN act relative to requiring all
municipalities and school governing
bodies to post on their official town or
School website within 30 days the
amounts of funds received by the state
either by allocation or Grant if it
consider the same report the same with
the following Amendment a recommendation
to Bill ought to pass with Amendment
committee the amendment is
15698 printed in house record 18 Pages
45- 46 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
oppos nay the eyes have it the amendment
is
adopted bills on second reading open to
further
Amendment Len terot office floor
Amendment
182h and is recognized to speak to his
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker um 1802
is a very simple bill um it it's quite
amazing that the committee on the other
side of the wall the full body on the
other side of the wall and I our entire
committee missed such a simple uh single
word uh that was caught by
representative spillsbury uh the
representative from Charleston um this
bill only changes the word current word
by it say says shall post the amount of
funds received by the state and it
changes it shall receive the funds uh
the funds received from the
State intent clarifies it uh we try to
make everything as as good as possible
before we send it back to the Senate so
we would ask that you uh agree with us
and press the green button thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us now is uh
Amendment floor
Amendment
182h are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I
suppose nay guys have it amendment is
adopted
representative bills on second reading
open to further Amendment representative
1847 and that's in your seat pockets and
Coker thank you Mr Speaker so uh this
floor Amendment uh 18
47 basically adds two bills um that went
through this house on a pretty good
margin uh to this bill for uh Senate
Bill 532 so the first bill is House Bill
1391 which allows new vehicles to be
inspected in the second year after
purchase um I've already gone through
the arguments twice uh on this bill in
the house I'm just going to hit the
bullet points and both times I went
through on a pretty good margin uh we
can make this change to our inspection
laws safely and it's going to save our
constituents millions of dollars and
it's going to save them 83,000 hours of
their time every year on unnecessary um
inspections so the second bill is HB
1032 which pass the house on a Voice
vote and basically what it does is um it
grants an exemption for cars that are
over um or for titles for cars that are
over 20 years old so right now the you
get an exemption for a title if the car
is
1999 or um earlier so 1999 was a long
time ago and this kind of makes it so
it's not like a set thing it it this
would basically put a 20-year Mark and
if the car is older than 20 years you
don't need a title so why does that
really matter one of the biggest issues
with this um everybody has a house in
the neighborhood that has like five old
cars the yard that are all beat up and
broken down and kind of just an eyesore
those are actually really hard to send
to the junkyard unless you have a title
um you can't even do it you'd have to go
get a duplicate title which gets really
complicated so this bill would make it
so a lot of those junk cars would be
able to get taken to the junkyard
recycled and get taken care of with uh
whatever way they need to go so um the
title is really not important on these
cars because the market value is pretty
low so again these two bills um let's
send it back to the other side of the
wall let them reconsider their position
and let's make life a little bit easier
for uh Granite Staters thank
you Vision has been requested members
seats
the motion before us is the Coker floor
Amendment 1847 this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Len
turkot for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this amendment contains two bills that
this body previously passed one by a
Voice vote one by 2/3 of this body and
if I also know both of these bills
reduce regulations as well as less the
financial burdens on our citizens would
I now vote green to amend these uh to
amend these two bills to the previously
passed house bills so we can send them
back to the body on the other side of
the wall thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us to cler ker for Amendment 1847
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposer press the red button
[Music]
represent
Johnson well members present have the
opportunity to vote I'll attend to state
253 voting y 104 voting nay committee am
amend amendment is
adopted we are now on ought to pass as
amended and chair recognizes
representative
off okay the motion before us now is are
the pass as amended are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it committee
adopted for what reason does the member
rise thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
having voted on the prevailing side of
Senate Bill 383 I move reconsideration
no the question is on reconsideration of
a division has been requested members
take your
seats representative Sweeny has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
the motion before us is reconsideration
on Senate Bill 383 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
all members present an opportunity to
vote 176 voting aay 185 voting aay the
motion
failed majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development to
which was referred Senate Bill 387 FN an
act relative to a state's Parks pass
pilot program for Recovery centers in
Community Mental Health Centers we
consider the same report the same with a
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interm study Senor Tim M for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
and being unable to agree with majority
Report with the recommendation Bill
ought to pass Senator Rosemary rung for
the minority of the commit
committee for what reason does a member
rise I Rise to make a motion Mr State
your motion my motion is I move to table
SB
387 that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table Senate Bill
387 are you ready for the qu a division
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill
chair recognized representative har for
this is a division vote chair recognized
representative har for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know we already have
another bill on State Park fees an
interim study would I now press the
green button and support this tabling
motion thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Vil for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill creat a study
and we do not need to interim study a
study and if I also know that Mental
Health Centers and the state parks
director have worked on a bill that is a
bipartisan Bill to support recovery in
New Hampshire for mental health recovery
centers and
for um our community mental health
centers then would I please press the
red button and we will hear a speech
against the interim study thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is to table
House Bill Senti pill 387 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposer
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
thank
you
HL while members president had an
opportunity vote also attend to State
the
vote 187 voting a 168 voting a Senate
table majority of the committee on
resource Recreation development to which
was referred Senate Bill 589 local act
relative to waste water SE charges
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation Bill ought
to pass sen timy for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the saying being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment representative will Derby
for the minority of the committee the
motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 589 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
adopted majority the committee on ways
and means to which was referred Senate
Bill 432 FN an act relative to Advanced
deposit account wagering and
establishing a chable third party
Financial intermediary program consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Fred duet for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation Bill ought to pass sen
Thomas shamberg for the minority of the
committee this is going to be a division
vote with pis only so members take your
the motion before us is Senate bill is
the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate on Senate Bill
432 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognized representative Malloy
okay the chair recognizes representative
Jian for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the
testimony was heard from multiple
sources that this bill could create a
gray area if passed between the federal
Interstate horse racing Act of 1978 and
New Hampshire RSA
22A and if I further know that all
revenue collected from Advanced deposit
wagering would be turned over to a
private third party who would decide
which Charities get that money
when currently simulcast and ADW Revenue
goes to the education trust
fund would I then support the 13 to6
bipartisan vote of itl and press the
green button thank you the majority the
motion before is a majority committee
report of inexpedient to legisl in
Senate Bill 432 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
jury all members president had an
vote 296 voting a 60 voting a committee
report is
adopted we're now on to bills removed
the committee on children and family law
to which was referred Senate Bill 574 an
act relative to the appointment of a
temporary agent for a minor child or
incapacitated person having considered
the same report the same with a
recommendation Bill ought to pass s of
committee floor amendment is being
offered
1853 it's in your seat pockets and the
ball thank you Mr Speaker several weeks
ago this body passed House Bill 185
anticipating that our colleagues on the
other side of the all would agree that
there is a pressing situation in New
Hampshire family courts that cannot wait
any longer to be addressed having worked
bipartisanly with members of the special
committee on Family Court we have
carefully examined the family court
system by observing and interviewing
judges listening to hours of
heartbreaking testimony and reviewing
past reports with recommendations on
challenges that this house should
address changing four words in RSA
461 will remove ambiguity from the law
thereby reducing the hostility between
parents and family courts this amendment
not only empowers the court to ensure
that all judges approach similar cases
consistently but also demonstrates that
the family courts in our great state of
New Hampshire are fully committed to the
intent of RSA
461 children do best when both parents
have stable and meaningful involvement
in their
lives replacing frequent and continuing
contact with approximately equal
parenting time in RSA 461 does not
diminish the authority of judges to use
their discretion in cases where equal
parenting time could be detrimental to
the child this amendment
continues to provide the exact same
protection to victims of domestic
violence abuse and neglect and is not
prevent parents from creating a
parenting plan that works for them I
implore my esteemed colleagues in the
house to show our constituents that we
have heard their pleas please press the
green button and pass this amendment to
make sure positive a positive difference
in the lives of New Hampshire families
thank
long thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
other side of the aisle already
determined on this uh
language um and that the underlying bill
is an important issue that we must take
up with respect to giv notice uh of a
grandparent or a family friend to uh
when a parent not not around to give per
give permission to take care of the
child uh we heard in committee that that
wasn't the case that there were some
doctors that refused those uh uh those
notices uh authorizing the other person
to take care of the child uh and if I
know that The Advocates and the service
providers um were strongly against this
approximately equal parenting time it
would create trouble because the court
needs to deem it clear detrimental to
the child and the current language of
frequent continuing contact gives the
judge the opportunity to determine
whether it's clearly detrimental to the
child or not uh and also that the um uh
that one parent both in a perfect world
uh both parents would have the best
interest of the child we all know that
this is not a perfect world there are
there are parents that don't have the
best interests of the child and that's
the concern that uh that's the concern
that I would have that this language
Speaker the motion before us is floor
Amendment
1853 division has been requested members
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1853 this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative post for
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that research involving three
30,000 children that that has shown that
shared parenting Arrangements has better
outcomes for children in terms of
emotional behavioral and psychological
well-being and that meaningful
relationships with both parents are
crucial for a child's emotional
development and tend to have higher
grades better School attendance lower
Dropout rates that are compared to
children in sole custody
arrangements and Mr Speaker children are
less likely to experience anxiety
depression and parliamentary inquiry yes
okay um and if I know that research
suggests that shared parenting can
reduce conflict between parents over
time as they cooperate in the best
interest of their children would I now
press the green button so that children
may Thrive with both fit parents in
their
lives please vote chair recognize
representative Raymond for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this floor amendment is entirely
unrelated to the underlying bill and if
I know that prior bills with similar
language to the amendment were opposed
by child welfare and domestic violence
experts because it does not put
children's best interests first and if I
know that the child and family law
committee has worked cooperatively to
vet and send bills forward with
unanimous support which this language
does not have and I believe we should
respect the work of the child and family
law committee would I now press the red
button to defeat the amendment and
consider the original Bill thank you
motion before us is floor Amendment 1853
on Senate Bill 574 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members present opportunity vote
vote 184 voting a 173 voting a the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now was ought to pass as amend as
amended the vision has been requested
seats represent Sweeney has a requested
a roll call as is that sufficiently
the motion before us is auto pass as
amended on Senate Bill 574 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
Corman while members president had an
opportunity to vote Al will tend to stay
the
vote 352 voting a seven voting a uh
committee on criminal justice and Public
Safety to which is referred Senate Bill
426 FN act relative to the
transportation of marijuana in a motor
vehicle or ohrv consider the same report
the same with the recommendation the
committee bills on second reading open
to further Amendment reprentative Manion
offers floor Amendment
1838 H it's in your seat Pockets the
Manion thank you Mr Speaker this
amendment adds the defend the guard act
SB 426 every month there's more
developments on the world stage that
justify the need for this act last month
Iranian missiles and drones flew over
three countries the US has Guardsmen
deployed to this month we're
constructing a pier in Gaza that will be
permanently staffed by our military
members I guess the Department of
Defense wasn't satisfied with over 100
bases we occupy worldwide and had to
manufacture a base over the sea to put
our men and women into a war zone
despite claims that there would not be
boots on the ground in Gaza while the
underlying bill is bad I ask that you
support this amendment to ensure the
other body knows that we are serious
about this issue and it won't be the
last time they see it thank you and I
ask for a roll call
kraton thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to this
floor Amendment this bill does not
protect the guard it hurts the guard I
served 34 years in the army deployed
over 10 all 10 of those with National
Guard
units I've been in discussion with the
adant general of New Hampshire who is
vehemently opposed to this bill at the
end of the day the National Guard cost
the federal government in for the State
of New Hampshire about $410
million that's Federal
money the state pays less than 4% of
that
amount there's Bill puts all that money
at risk the missions that we go on today
to
Kuwait to Honduras to anywhere in the
Middle East would be canceled based on
the language in this in this
bill if I'm the federal government in
the state of New Hampshire says hey I'm
not going that $410 million is gone and
we have no National guarden in New
Hampshire for that reason I am opposed
to this bill I think it's a bad Bill and
puts us in trouble please Pro please P
red thank
you representative Manion has requested
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
sure
motion before us is the Manion floor
amendment 18 38h this is a roll call
vote chair recognized represent a Manion
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the Secretary of Defense Austin stated
that up to 1,000 service members will be
operating a new pier in the Gaza Strip
and if I further know he testified that
there is a high likely scenario that the
servicemen will come under Fire while
operating this pier and finally if I
know during the same testimony the SE
def claims this doesn't constitute boots
on the ground implying military
occupation works by the same rules as
the floor is lava then would I press the
green button to pass this
amendment chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr speaker with
respect to the member from pelum Mr
Speaker if I know that the New Hampshire
National Guard and the a National Guard
are a very important components of Our
National Defense and Mr Speaker if I
know that the last time there has been a
congressional declaration of war was on
December 8th
1941 and Mr Speaker if I know as someone
who served in the regular army and
served in Vietnam on February of 1968
during the had offensive and was very
glad that the 197 field artillery of the
New Hampshire National Guard was part of
Three core would I now push the red
button to defeat this amendment thank
you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is floor
amendment 18
38h this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppos or press the red button
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
vote 126 voting yay 231 voting nay the
motion
fails now we're on to the original
committee for what reason do a member
rise to make a motion State your motion
uh table SB
426 the motion is in order a motion
before us is the table Senate Bill 4
426 are you ready a division has been
requested everybody still should be in
your
seats the motion is to table Senate Bill
426 if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
representative
all members president have opportunity
vote 141 voting a 216 voting a the
motion
fails now we're back to the original
motion of aut pass on Senate Bill 426
we do have a
debate jerck it's on the mo motion of
autop pass chair recognized
representative alisandra
Murray thank you Mr Speaker and
honorable members of the house I Rise to
urge you to vote against the aut to pass
motion on SB
426 which would impose duplicative and
excessive penalties on cannabis
transported in a motor vehicle while I
voted for this bill in committee I've
since realized my error in doing so for
those over 21 SB 426 would impose a $150
fine and a possible driver's license
suspension for possession of cannabis
and a motor vehicle unless it's either
in its original container with the
sealing broken or in a trunk for
vehicles without a trunk the glove box
or compartment location least accessible
to the driver for those under 21 s426
would impose $150 fine and a possible
driver's license suspension regardless
of where in the vehicle that cannabis is
more than 70% of New Hampshire voters
want to see cannabis legalized for
adults s SP 426 moves in the opposite
direction under current law any
possession of cannabis is already
subjected to a $100 civil fine for a
first or second offense with escalating
penalties for each subsequent offense s
SP 426 creates a duplicative penalty
totaling at least
$250 that amount is unaffordable to a
large number of Americans and is enough
to cause many to miss rent the driver's
license suspension poses a serious
economic hardship as well by making it
impossible or cost prohibitive to go to
work the reasons for having an open
container law for alcohol don't make
sense in the context of cannabis
containers of cannabis typically include
many days of servings whereas alcohol is
often sold in single serving beer cans
cannabis Edibles are usually sold with
100 milligrams of tea HC per package or
10 servings of 10 milligram each unlike
alcohol edi's effect is typically
delayed for 45 minutes or longer
Americans who in Vibe can typically get
alcohol at their destination bars
restaurants sporting events Etc whereas
cannabis consumers always need to bring
cannabis with them if they're going to
use it at their destination and their
container of cannabis will always be
open once they've used any in short any
open container of cannabis is not
indicative
of whether they were consuming cannabis
while driving impaired driving is
already illegal there is no need for
this new penalty which would not
increase safety it would merely ensnare
people unaware of the law including
drivers and passengers traveling from
Maine and Massachusetts which have legal
cannabis and no open container law keep
in mind that legislation the house
already passed hb1 1633 would address
and impose additional fines for driving
under the influence if we pass this bill
today we risk increasing penalties and
restrictions on cannabis without
legalizing recreational use which goes
against what granted Staters clearly
want please reject s426 which would
impose excessive and duplicative
penalties and overturn the OTP motion so
a better motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker do a member yield or
questions sure member yields uh thank
you for taking my question in some of my
research for the legalization bill I saw
that there are some sort of single
serving that are sealed they're sort of
jumbo joints that are huge but they are
sealed individually do you think this
would encourage more people to to buy
and use those oversized joints instead
of more reasonable cannabis I think
potentially if they're trying to avoid
being caught with a quote unquote open
container thank
roads thank you Mr speaker Mr Speaker
this bill was brought to us by the
department of safety and we really
didn't hear a whole lot of opposition to
it as a matter of fact that came out of
our committee 19
to1 with that being said regardless of
how many people want marijuana to be
legal in the state of New Hampshire it's
not going to be legal to operate a
vehicle if you're high and the way this
bill is written is that is what it aims
to go against it is going to basically
put marijuana in the same class of
driving with an open container if you
have a medical marijuana card and that
is what you're transporting is your
medical marijuana that is excluded in
this bill so at the end of the day if
you're driving down the road and you do
happen to have some marijuana with you
please keep it in your trunk please keep
it in your glove BLX just like if you
have container you're not going to drive
down the road with it open don't drive
the down the road while you're smoking a
joint thank you Mr
Speaker representative roads has
seats representative rhs has requested a
the motion before us is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 426 this is a division vote
chair recognized representative Manion
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know s
SP 426 is backd door rep penalizing
small amounts of marijuana possession
and if I know original packaging is
nonsense when're referring to just about
all marijuana storage and if I know we
should not be expanding the open
container law then would I press red
button to overturn the committee
recommendation on S SP 426 thank you
chair recognize representative RS for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill was brought to us by the department
of safety because they needed help to be
able to address when people are
operating Vehicles while they're high
and if I know that this bill came out of
the committee 19 to1 and I know that
there's no reason to take this off the
consent calendar would I now vote where
are we at green with the
committee motion before us is a to pass
in Senate Bill 426 this say division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose or press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
G all members president had an
opportunity vote houseold tend to stay
to the
vote 194 voting a 160 voting a the
adop committee on criminal justice and
Public Safety to which was referred
Senate Bill 508 FN an act relative to
the duties of the superintendent of the
County Department of Corrections
concerning mental health and substance
abuse disorder screening of the inmates
and the coordination for services upon
re-entry into the community considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and recommendation
of the bill ought to pass with Amendment
S Terry Roy for the for the committee
the amendment is
1728 printed in house record 18 pages 4
47 the debate is going to be on the
amendment chair recogniz representative
Son
nasto thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the committee amendment to Senate Bill
508 adds a definition of anti-semitism
to New Hampshire's anti-discrimination
laws this addition is firstly
unnecessary
our current law already sufficiently
protects Jewish people from
discrimination it broadly prohibits
discrimination based on race Creed color
marital status familial status physical
or mental disability religion or
national origin which includes
discrimination against uh which is Brad
enough to includes discrimination
against Jewish
individuals uh sorry I got mix up here
okay this is Broad enough to cover
Jewish identity
uh but this is also destructive for many
reasons firstly by explicitly defining
anti-Semitism in the law there might be
an implication that the existing
protections are insufficient which could
undermine the comprehensiveness and
balance of the current
anti-discrimination
statutes this is to say inserting a
special definition for anti-Semitism
suggests that other groups could be
discriminate against since they do not
have explicit laws protecting them we'd
have to insert similar explicit
protections for Palestinians black
people gay people and every other signal
group this is why we have the concept of
categories so we don't have to list
every single possible instance of a
group of people that could be
discriminated
against moreover the definition of
anti-semitism that this amendment wants
to include is the definition adopted on
May 26
2016 by the international Holocaust
remembrance Alliance the definition
States
anti-Semitism is a certain perception of
Jews which may be as expressed as a
hatred towards Jews rhetorical and
physical manifestations of anti-Semitism
are directed towards Jewish or
non-jewish individuals Andor their
property towards Jewish Community
institutions and religious
facilities when such a definition is way
too
broad if incorporated into statue it can
have quasi legal effects that may impact
freedom of speech there is concern about
whether criticism of the state of Israel
for example or the ADL might sometimes
be labeled as anti-semitic under such
definitions impacting legitimate
political expression this definition
vagueness could politically be exploited
to suppress legitimate discourse or
political criticism not directly related
to anti-emetic
intent besides being overly broad the
definition proposed is also in
appropriate it is entirely possible to
hold negative opinions and even Harbor
negative sentiments towards Jewish
community community institutions and
religious uh groups without
discriminating against
individuals this proposed amendment in
part suggests regulating our thoughts
about institutions by applying such
opinions on institutions are inherently
discriminatory towards individual Jewish
people this is a troubling overreach
that conflicts individual
with institutional
criticism uh potentially stifling
legitimate
discourse Mr Speaker I urge the body to
reject this reactionary measure thank
Bickford
yes thank you Mr Mr Speaker
glasses I oppose I Rise to oppose the
amendment this is not the time or the
place to be doing this just to be cool
these are tough times we know what's
going on in Israel we know Palestine and
maybe we want to do something for them
but carving out a special circumstance
for one group in the Discrimination laws
is
counterintuitive and creates a type of
reverse discrimination against all
others not getting similar
considerations George elal the author
back in 1945 wrote the book The Animal
Farm and in the area he talked about the
thought police but he also said after
the revolution of the
animals they said they were all equal
all animals are equal but some animals
are more equal than others and this is
where this sort of thing takes us and we
don't want to go that way go the
opposite direction by doing
this all groups deserve the same
attention not some more than others now
yesterday there was an article put out
by former executive counselor
binsky those of you the Democrats have
been around for I know him he was the
one that uh that won the clamon decision
he's Jewish he makes no bones about it
he doesn't want this sort of thing he
didn't approve of what happened at the
national level
but that and we should we should all
feel that way not just Democrats or
Republicans we should care about all of
us and not treat one with greater
sympathy than the
other so I hope that you'll press red on
roads thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker this bill will not make it
I'm sorry this amendment my apologies
this amendment will not make it illegal
to be able to go out and
protest we were all at lunch today we
all heard the individual that was
outside screaming from the top of her
lungs she's allowed to do that as long
as she wants it's not illegal to do that
but what will be illegal is to commit a
crime while you're doing that this
amendment will make it where if a crime
is committed the authorities will
actually be able to investigate the
entire scope of the
action we heard that this is already
illegal yes committing crime is already
illegal however when people come to our
committee which they do a lot and they
want to be able to track certain kind of
crimes or they want certain things to be
illegal we actually do not have a
definition of what a hate crime is we
don't every single person in our
committee has our law book out and we're
always looking it's not there this will
make it be
there this does not penalize anybody's
right to free expression it explicitly
States nothing contained in this bill is
to be construed to diminish or infringe
upon any right protected under the first
amendment in the United States
Constitution uh Additionally the reason
that this language is what was adopted
is because this has already been
codified or adopted by 33 other states
and this is the exact language that the
consent I I I think there's you know a
lot more here but I think at the end of
the day we we all actually get to the
point of this and I would ask you to
please vote for the committee Amendment
does the member yield to questions no
member does not
yield representative wheeler has
requested a roll call is that
yes it is sufficiently seconded members
the motion the motion before us is the
amendment 1728 H this is a roll call
vote chair recognize representat wheeler
for a parliamentary
inre thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that we shouldn't be codifying a
private organization's very broad
definition of what anti-Semitism is in t
La when there is not a definition for
racism sexism islamophobia name it and
if M Mr Speaker I know that this
legislation was opposed in the United
States Congress by members on
diametrically different sides of the
aisles such as Ralph uh such as Jerry
Nadler and Matt Gates then Mr Speaker
would I against this legislation because
this is too broad and it chills freedom
of speech as the ACLU has said Thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognized
representative rhs for parliamentary
inquiring Mr Speaker if I know that by
adopting this
amendment this definition will reduce
the likelihood that the definition will
be improperly
modified if I know that this bill has
this amendment has already been adopted
in our committee by 19 out of 20 of the
people that are in there and if I know
that the
ACLU also is against whenever a person
wants to use a child in pornograph of
committee the motion before us is the
amendment
17 28h this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
second voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 189 voting a 160 voting aay the
amendment is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker State your
sb58 motion is in order the motion
before us is to table Senate Bill 508 FN
and uh she asked representative Reed
asked for a division members
take Spain ask for a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
the motion before us is to table Senate
Bill 508 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Reed for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that I read the amendment that
just passed very carefully including the
documents that the amendment referen
but does not spell out and that those
documents first the international
Holocaust remembrance
Association the definition of
anti-semitism being only two sentences
but also the 11 examples that they did
not adopt but that this amendment adopts
and that those and if Mr Speaker if I
further know that seven of those 11
examples of anti-Semitism have to do
with criticizing the government of
Israel and further Mr Speaker if I know
that also the amendment codifies a 2019
presidential executive order and I know
that approximately half of this body
probably would not like to cify a 2019
presidential executive
order and finally if I know that I want
to be able to criticize any government
without being called hateful of a
religion or a Creed I would like to
criticize the Italian government without
being called anti-catholic or the Indian
government without being called
anti-hindu then Mr Speaker would I now
press the green button and table this
bill until we can figure out how to pass
the underlying bill without this bad
Amendment thank you chair recognize
representative RS for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we should not table this
bill because the house just voted 189 to
160 to pass the
amendment would I now press red on the
the motion before us is the table Senate
Bill 508 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
while members president had the
opportunity to vote also will tend to
vote 168 voting a 186 voting a the
now we're back to the question of autop
pass as
amended are you ready for the
question a division has been
requested every everybody should still
seats members take your seats this will
the motion before us is the committee
report of Auto passes amended on Senate
Bill 508 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
B M present had an opportunity to vote
vote 210 voting y 143 voting a committee
committee on executive departments and
administration to which was referred
Senate Bill 481 an act relative to
establishing juneth June 19th as an
annual holiday have consider the same
report the same the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate sen of Sher Gul for the
committee are you ready for the are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
I those poos say
[Applause]
[Music]
nay a division has been requested only
after
vo all right the motion be this is going
to be a division to for
clarification if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose
you'll press the red button voting
[Music]
all members present had the opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 194 voting yay 184 voting nay
committee report is
adopted before we go on to the third
reading motion I'd like to uh say this
week is legislative staff week I would
like to I wait a minute wait a minute I
would like to thank the general court
staff who contribute to the day-to-day
operations of the house each of you make
a tremendous difference and on behalf of
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives I want to thank all of
you for your dedication and commitment
you are truly in my humble opinion the
best staff of the nation thank you let's
give them a help of a
[Applause]
hand the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third read motion
thank you Mr Speaker resolve that the
house now adjourned from the early
session that the business of the late
session be in order at the present time
that the reading of bills be by title
only and resolutions by caption only and
that all bills ordered a third reading
be read a third time by this resolution
and that all titles of bills be the same
as adopted and that they be pass at the
present time and when the house adjourns
chair members please stay in your seat
we got some announcements and some
unanimous consents the question is on a
third reading motion are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I
those Close n the eyes have it the
motion is adopted chair recognizes
announcement if you have never been in
the State House lawn when they've shot
off a cannon I'm inviting you to May
20th at 3pm. to celebrate the 200th
anniversary of when General Lafayette
came and stood in this chamber chamber
come join us at 3:00 it'll be a great
show outside and you'll learn more about
him here 3:00 May
it thank you Mr
Speaker since we are not having session
next week and this is a little out of
the norm for our meetings this is a
heads up for the marrat county
delegation uh we're going to to have an
executive committee and full delegation
meeting on Monday May 20th rather than
the Friday before Memorial Day Weekend
you're
welcome the member will suspend for a
minute the member is giving us an
announcement it she has a right to
present that announcement and be heard
so please everybody just we're almost
done give everybody a break here may you
m continue thank you Mr Speaker speaker
this meeting again will be Monday May
20th at 10:00 a.m. at the Old Courthouse
in conquered this will be for the
purpose of authorizing salaries for
County elected
officers which must be completed prior
to the filing date in June I believe
it's going to be a fairly brief meeting
I hope to see you all there thank you
chair recogize representative Lon for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker next
Wednesday from noon to 1 at St Paul's
there will be a lunch from the American
Cancer Society to discuss to discuss
biomarkers and cancer um I know this is
an important issue and it'll be a great
lunch and learn if you'll join us thank
you chair recognize repres sen Burnham
consent thank you Mr Speaker and fellow
Representatives this Sunday we are
celebrating Mother's Day and many of us
uh will be honoring or receiving honor
for the love work and toil that mothers
so often provide likewise next month we
will be celebrating Father's Day for
similar reasons the proclamation that I
hold was signed by the speaker on May
7th to celebrate that time interval
between Mother's Day and Father's Day As
Natural family month this Proclamation
recognizes that all families are
important and recognizes the family unit
as a solid foundation where our children
can grow and strive natural family month
is part of a growing Nationwide movement
celebrated on a state level in Maine
Louisiana Wisconsin Ohio and in a
multitude of other states at the
community level in cities towns and
churches this movement is headed by the
natural Family Foundation to encourage
parental involvement to promote honest
and open communication between families
to recognize the important role of each
parent and to restore Family Values I
was not raised with my biological father
my grandparents helped my mom and that
made our family different although not
having a dad during those vital years
gave me the desires to want a family
with these strong family values my
experience experience helped me to find
the strength to raise my children and my
husband to en with my husband to enjoy
the good times and work hard through the
tough times strong family values make
strong families and strong families make
strong people as a wife of almost 28
years a mother of four amazing daughters
and a grandmother of three beautiful
grandbabies please join me in supporting
and encouraging New Hampshire families
in this Proclamation and celebration of
natural family month beginning May 12th
Mother's Day through June 16th Father's
Day to help spread the word we have yard
signs available for a modest price of $8
each I have them available in the
store's garage and you can also visit
natural family strong.com to learn more
and purchase resour ources there to
encourage this family movement thank you
support chair recognized representative
ma
py thank
you thank you Mr
speaker May is Asian American n native
Hawaiian Pacific Islander Heritage Month
May is also better speech and hearing
month May's mental health awareness
month I'm not going to talk about all
three I'm going to be talking a little
bit about may as Asian-American native
Hawaiian Pacific Islander Heritage Month
in the month of May and I'm happy to see
my
colleagues of of Asian American Heritage
and I recognize across the aisle there's
another um colleague of mine in the
month of May we take time to reflect and
celebrate the important role that
asian-americans native Hawaiians in the
Pacific Islander have played in our
shared history the month of May was
chosen because it commemorates the
immigration of the first immigrants from
Japan to the United States in May 7 on
May 7th
1843 you heard that this morning and to
celebrate the completion of the
Transcontinental Railroad by many Asian
immigrants on May 10th
1869 however the first Asian immigrant
arrived in us in in
1587 when Filipinos first became
migrants to
California immigrants continued to come
from the Asian continent and the Pacific
Islands through 1920 when the first uh
simonian Samoans were documented in
Hawai in 21st century we have
substantial Asian-American American
Pacific Islander population in United
States of America this population is
contributing in 21st century economic
impact cultural and arts in general
participating in economic
patriotism I am proud to stand with my
fellow
Asian-American native Hawaiian Pacific
Islander representatives and like I said
I recognize the colleague on the other
side of the
aisle
Asian-American native Hawaiian and
Pacific Islander heritage month is
observed annually in May to celebrate
the contributions that generations of
aapis have made to American history
society and culture a little bit of
history about um Heritage
Month in 2024
uh I'm proud to announce that the theme
for May 2024 observance of um aapi
heritage month is advancing leaders
through
Innovation this year's theme is the
culmination of uh 2021 to
2024 um series highlighting our nation's
effort to advancing
leaders including our vice president who
is our of Asian
Heritage and now Heritage Month history
June 30th 1977 the origin of aapi
Heritage Month dates back to the 95th
Congress when five joint resolutions
were introduced proposing that a week in
may be designated to commemorate the
accomplishments of aapis the House of
Representatives introduced three joint
resolution utions and I'm not going to
read the numbers of the resolutions to
designate the first 10 days in May as
aapi Heritage week while Senator Daniel
in inui also introduced joint resolution
72 in the Senate to designate the
beginning of May as Pacific Islander
Heritage week a fourth joint
resolution uh was introduced in the
house of reps by Frank representative
Frank Horton and proposed designating
seven days in the May beginning on May
4th so I'm just giving you the history
because it started as a week 10 days and
now how we ended up as a month of
Heritage um this law directed the
president to issue a proclamation
designated week beginning in on May 4th
1979 9 as aapi Heritage week March
28th 1978 President Carter issued
Proclamation 4 4650 the first
presidential Proclamation for Asian
American Pacific Islander Heritage week
in this Proclamation President Carter
spoke of the significant role
asian-americans have played in the
creation of a dynamic and pluralistic
American society with their
contributions to the science Arts
industry government and commerce over
the next 10 years President Carter
President Reagan President George HW
Bush continued to annually issue
Proclamation designating a week in May
as uh aapi Heritage
week in on May 7th 19 1990 President
George W bush issued presidential proc
Proclamation
6130 designating May 1990 as the first
Asian-American heritage month so in 1990
changed from a week to a month Congress
passed a resolution which amended the
previous resolution as a week requested
the president to issue and Proclamation
which expanded the law called on people
of United United States to observe
Asian-American heritage month with
appropriate ceremonies programs and
activities for which I can invite you on
May 19th we are having a huge
celebration in
nashwa
32 no 4 to
six
um May 14th
1991 was passed unanimously by Congress
dis um signed by President judge W bush
this law requested that the president
Proclamation uh Proclaim
May uh 1991 and may 1992 as aapi month
this law also recognizes the
significance of May 7th and May 10th in
the history of
aapi this was the first initial
in May of each
year from since then may of each year is
recognized as aapi heritage month
and I acknowledge that we have grown in
our own body here with four
aapi reps and I'm proud to join that and
thank you for your Indulgence in leting
his
[Applause]
Howard hello Mr Speaker and fellow
Representatives
wait a
second the first amendment protects the
most fundamental rights to American
democracy and is the foundation of the
American dream the United States was
founded on the idea of freedom of speech
that is freedom of conscience the idea
that citizens of this new type of
Democratic Republic are free to choose
their own dreams and promote their own
ideas including those that other Su uh
other citizens of the or the state may
find inconvenient objectionable or even
important there is no other right more
fundamental to the modern idea of
democracy which was conceived here in
the United States of America this is a
request that the state understands that
the first amendment is the most
fundamental point of law in American
democracy without it for what does the
Constitution stand for what have
millions of Americans fought and died
overseas for what have did our ancestors
wage the revolution fight the Civil War
and defeat Nazism in Europe last
Wednesday's arrest on University
campuses around our state of both Pro
Palestinian protesters and pro-israeli
counter-protesters was an attack on
students ability to exercise such rights
as a student at the University of New
Hampshire I know my peers and I am
personally familiar with the events that
transpired last Wednesday's event
organizers the graduate student Senate
an integral part of the University had
gone through all the proper channels to
obtain permitted approval for their
demonstration interestingly UNH police
arrived right when Union organizers were
scheduled and advertised to meet there's
absolutely no justification for the way
law enforcement handled this situation
as they failed to do even the bare
minimum to protect students rights and
wait for the scheduled event to
conclude regardless of opinions of is
happening in Palestine this is an
assault on the First Amendment despite
patently false claims from University
Police nothing that the event organizers
did in any way violated the law or even
school policy even if such a violation
had occurred it would be the fault of
the university for maintaining an
unconstitutional policy all 12 of those
who were arrested were members of the
UNH Community despite claims that
outside agitators were the cause the
statistics suggest suggest
otherwise there this isn't only about
students protesting for Palestine and to
that end pro-israel counter protesters
who are likewise protected by the First
Amendment also had their rights
flagrantly violated by the University of
New Hampshire the New Hampshire State
Police and the New Hampshire Army
National Guard last week the house
reaffirmed those uh students rights by
voting down SB 439 which would have
banned BDS
protests according to the nation
uh report from the foundation for
individual rights and uh and expression
UNH is ranked third in the nation for
free speech on campus isn't that ranking
uh something that we want to improve and
not uh make
worse the state must drop all charges
being brought both against protesters
and
counter-protesters by encouraging
University administrators to open and
keep lines of communications with
student groups uh and work
collaboratively to support the First
Amendment uh regardless of uh of the
situation we need to ensure Safety and
Security for everyone while making sure
that they can practice their first
[Applause]
W thank you Mr Speaker colleagues I Rise
to apologize on two of the previous
sessions I made loud remarks to two
separate people I have since apologized
to those two people but I had no right
to breach the decorum of this house and
its protocol
call and I apologize many of you other
others heard my loud remarks I apologize
[Applause]
sorry represent hosman moves at the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills and Ro build
amendments Ro build reports vacate
motions receiving messages inform
forming committees at conference are you
ready for the question all those in
I guys have it house is in recess to the